[MUSIC PLAYING]
KASTNER: Experiments
were done up the street.
And if you walk across through
Building 9 into Building 13,
you can find the offices
where Bob Laughlin yelled
at me and his thesis
advisor, John Joannopoulos,
for many years.
We really feel as though
this is a family affair.
And we're really delighted
that Bob and Dan and Horst
all agreed to come
and speak today.
I want to express
thanks on behalf
of the Physics Department
to Dave Litster,
the Vice President for
research and Dean for research
for helping to support this.
And for the Francis
Bitter Magnet Lab.
Bob Griffin also
helped support it.
And I especially want to mention
the David Harris lecture fund.
David Harris was
a student at MIT.
And before his death, he
discussed with his family
a memorial that he would like.
And he wanted a
memorial which would
be a living memorial as
opposed to hardware or bricks
and mortar.
And so his family endowed a fund
which provides resources for us
to bring distinguished lectures
to the physics department
each year.
And this year we're especially
delighted that that's
being used to help
support this symposium.
So now, I'd like to call
upon Dave Litster, who
would like to say a few words.
Dave.
LITSTER: Thank you, Marc.
It says here another welcome.
I'm not sure you
need another welcome.
But I think the
reason I was asked
to do this is to indicate
that this lecture series is
an important part of
the intellectual life
of the Institute as a whole
and that what's happening
this afternoon is also important
to the rest of the Institute
and not just the
Physics Department.
So I welcome you.
I was thinking about
this prize a little bit.
And the thing that-- the
idea that popped into my head
is that, very often, those
of us who do basic science,
experimental basic
science, especially
owe an enormous debt of
gratitude to technology.
But we seldom
acknowledge it publicly.
But it's very important.
And this Nobel Prize
would never have
happened without some very
important pieces of technology.
Sometimes, the basic scientists
have to develop the technology
themselves.
And here, I see there were
three important technological
ingredients.
The first was these
very special materials
with very high
electron mobility.
And those were developed
by Horst and Dan
together with Art Gossard
at Bell Laboratories.
Without those, the experiments
could not have been done.
Secondly, the
experiments required
very high magnetic fields.
And those happened to be
available at the Francis Bitter
Laboratory and no place
else in the country.
And so the experiments
were done here.
I think Peter Wolff
will be telling us
more later this evening for
those who were there about it.
And the third bit of
technology is something
that people refer to
as wet technology.
It was the unusual brain
of Bob Laughlin who
happens to be able
to think about things
in a way different
from most of us
and, therefore, was
able to explain this.
So I think it's going to be
an interesting afternoon.
In fact, it's going to be
a real intellectual treat.
And I will sit down so that
Bob Griffin can proceed
and we can get it started.
Thank you.
GRIFFIN: Well, thank
you, Marc and Dave.
I'm here because I'm
Director, presently,
the Director of the Francis
Bitter Magnet Laboratory.
And as many of you know, being
Director of the Magnet Lab
has been like being
captain of a--
the last few years, at least--
being captain of a ship sailing
on a really pretty rough sea.
Some people-- one
of my colleagues
described us like being
captain of the Titanic even.
But we've had some very good
experiences, nevertheless
during the last few years.
And many of those were
associated with visits
from Horst Stormer and Dan Tsui.
I mean, we're very closely
connected, of course,
with the experimental aspects
of the fractional quantum Hall
effect.
As Dave Litster just mentioned,
the fractional quantum Hall
effect was actually discovered
at the Francis Bitter National
Magnet Laboratory at that time.
And it was actually
approximately 18 years ago
today, yesterday rather.
I don't know if you realize
that, October 7, 1981.
And we're converging
to the opinion
that the experiment
may have been done
in cell four of the Magnet Lab.
Maybe Horst and Dan can
comment on that later on.
But we owe Horst and Dan a very
great thank you, a very big
thank you.
They have been an
enormous help to the lab.
And I think
everybody at the lab,
particularly myself,
really appreciates what
they have done for the lab.
And perhaps more than
whatever we did for them.
And so I would like to express
the gratitude of the laboratory
and its members to both of
those individuals for all
of the nice
interactions we've had.
And also to add our
congratulations to everyone
here on the award of
the 1998 Nobel Prize.
KASTNER: Thanks, Bob.
So now I'm going to
call on Ray Ashoori, who
was post-doc with Horst
Stormer at Bell Labs
before he came to the MIT
faculty to introduce Horst.
ASHOORI: Well, it's a
pleasure and an honor for me
to introduce Horst.
Horst has been at Bell
Labs since completing
his PhD at the University
of Stuttgart in 1977.
And he started at
Bell as a post-doc
and a year later
became a regular member
of technical staff.
And following sort of a meteoric
rise, three or four years
later became a
department head, head
of the famous semiconductor
physics department
which is where the
transistor was invented.
And he became, after that,
director of physics research
in 1991.
He's now a professor
at Columbia.
And he still holds an adjunct
director position at Bell.
By the mid-1980s, when
I was in grad school,
Horst was already quite famous.
In fact, I remember one
of the older students
in my lab having boasted,
I saw Horst Stormer.
And a lot of other adjectives
came along with that.
But you can imagine how
thrilled I was when he chose me
as a post-doc back in 1990.
So the first thing I
noticed coming into the lab
was just an amazing
amount of inventiveness
and a little bit
of outrageousness
that I think led Horst to
do a lot of great things.
The first or second day
in the lab, he asked me,
can you solder?
I said, sure, I can solder.
I thought it was just
soldering wires together.
What he meant was,
can you sit up
on this table on top of a stool
and solder a couple of wires--
solder, under a microscope, on
the end of a long probe that we
used, a low
temperature probe, and
solder little microscopic wires
on this sort of flimsy set up.
And the idea was--
we had an idea--
he had an idea for a
very novel experiment.
And I was a little bit reticent
about sitting up on the stool.
So he showed me first that
it could, indeed, be done.
So it's this kind of
spirit that made it
just a tremendous amount
of fun to be there.
Way back when he
was a post-doc, he
invented a technique
for growing ultra
pure semiconductor materials
called modulation doping.
And this discovery--
or this invention
was one of the key
items, I think,
in finally giving rise to the
discovery of fractional quantum
Hall effect that he and Dan Tsui
did here, as you've all heard.
And this kind of
structure, actually-- it
has had some
technological relevance,
in that, if you
have a cell phone,
you've got transistors
made out of this kind
of ultra pure material
that Horst invented.
And some of these ideas that
he's had, in retrospect they
seem so simple and
maybe even obvious.
But of course, before
you make the discovery,
before you have the idea,
it's not at all obvious.
And Horst is known,
I think, for just
seeing with amazing clarity
what needs to be done.
Here's another sort of
outrageous thing that he did.
He invented a technique called
cleaved edged overgrowth, which
you take a wafer that you grow.
It's very thin wafer.
You cleave it inside
of a machine that's
used for growing these wafers.
And you actually grow on
this thin edge of a wafer.
OK.
This allows you to
make, it turns out,
perfect one-dimensional
structures.
And the technique itself is
difficult enough, but on top
of this, when I came to his lab
he's actually doing lithography
on this half-millimeter edge.
So imagine doing lithography--
the kind that's normally done
on big semiconductor wafers--
on a very tiny edge.
And I was just amazed at the
outrageousness of this quest.
He actually made it work.
And he has done beautiful
1D experiments--
experiments on
one-dimensional wires since.
I also-- here, I'm blessed
with being near Peter Wolff who
was Director of the
Magnet Lab at the time
Horst and Dan made
the discovery.
And I just love listening to
his stories about Horst and Dan
during that time and how they--
when they discovered the
fractional quantum Hall effect.
First of all, they're
working inside
of a very noisy big magnet where
there's giant currents running
through the spinner
magnet, water
rushing through it, making
the whole system vibrate.
This bore is about
two centimeters wide.
Now, imagine you have room
temperature outside this bore.
Inside the bore, you want
it to be 50 millikelvin.
So you somehow have to
develop a refrigerator that
cools your samples
down to 50 millikelvin.
Horst and Dan did it,
and that, of course,
is what got them the prize.
So you can see how this
kind of inventiveness
is just critical to
this kind of discovery.
Here's another story
about the first day
on the job with Horst.
He has tremendous energy.
And you see this in
the way he walks,
because you just can't
keep up with him.
So what I would notice is that
he walks so fast that I would--
I couldn't walk as fast.
So I'd end up
running a few steps,
then walking a few steps,
and running a few steps.
And this is how we
progressed to lunch every day
during my two
years of Bell Labs.
After Horst became
director, and that
was after my first year
at Bell, after a year,
he would still come
down to the lab,
and he would do things like
help me change the pump oil.
You know, what a completely
mundane job for Nobel
Prize-winning director.
He's getting up because
he's getting sick of this.
But you could see
you could see in him
that there was a real love
of just being in the lab.
All right.
Let me end with this.
Horst has received every physics
award imaginable, the Buckley
Prize, the Nobel Prize,
the Franklin Medal,
he's in the National
Academy of Sciences.
He's a truly, I think,
extraordinary and rare person.
And it's just a thrill to have
them here just for the day.
Here's Horst.
[APPLAUSE]
STORMER: Is this on?
Is this on?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
STORMER: Ray, you haven't
gotten any briefer.
But thanks very much.
I'm-- it's just too much honor.
Thanks.
Thanks very-- I must say--
you hear more and
more of these things,
and you start wondering
about yourself.
But, all I can say, I'm
a very lucky guy that
has worked with
tremendous people,
and not just collaborators
but also then
in the form of post-docs,
and Ray is one of those.
And there are several
others around.
And they give me
all this credit.
And it's just not true.
It's these guys that did it.
And that Ray says help changing
pump oil was very easy.
It's the only thing I can do.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a pleasure
to be back at what
was, for many years,
our part-time home,
not far down here.
Sort of a place
you really wouldn't
want to call home
when you walk into it.
It's a loud and
noisy environment.
But Dan Tsui and I came
there for many years
doing our experiments,
eating cold pizza
and drinking warm Coke, looking
at data on chart recorder
coming out, and singing
together with our grad students
funny songs from Monty Python.
It was a really good
time for a few years
that-- well, actually,
it must be about a decade
that we came up here.
So it's a pleasure
to be back at MIT.
It doesn't mean that I haven't
been back in the meantime
visiting old friends, and many
of them are in the audience.
There's actually too many
to go through one by one.
If I do it, I know I'm
going to forget one of them,
so I better don't.
So we have three hours.
I'm not sure the
audience how long
you're going to hold
out for three hours.
But I have the advantage
of having the first hour,
and Bob has the last hour.
[LAUGHS] So let's see
what we're going to do.
That's my first--
can I take this off?
No.
Almost not.
You can imagine we're doing
a lot of these recently.
Actually, the two of us, Bob
and I, have been on a tour
through Scandinavia.
And we started feeling very
much like these gentlemen.
It's just a good one that--
[LAUGHTER]
And it hasn't it hasn't
stopped much since then.
I'm looking very much forward
to Wednesday, next week.
I hope that some
of the burden is
going to be taken off from us.
But I'm afraid it's not going
to be condensed metaphysics,
so it still will be rough going.
In fact, when I told Bob that--
I did this when we
went to Stockholm,
and I had only the
pieces with me.
I told Bob that I
would be doing this.
And he said, yeah, and I knew
it who's going to be Pavarotti.
[LAUGHTER]
I told him, of course, the best.
So I'm actually--
along in this vein,
I thought, this is, of course,
all this it's a great honor
and it is a wonderful,
wonderful week,
and we had a very good time.
And how good a time we had
is perhaps shown in this one.
You come in in the morning, and
you are sleepy and not shaved
and washed, because
you get off the plane.
And so they want you
to take a photograph
in front of the King.
This is the King.
Yeah.
I remember, I swear,
Lou told a Viagra joke.
No.
I tell you why we're laughing.
And you know why we're laughing.
The Viagra jokes
were old by then.
So they get you in
front of the camera.
And what all photographers
do is-- you're never
close enough, right?
Photographers always do that.
And because they have
one hand on the camera
they do it like this.
So they wanted us to
stand closer together.
And, you know, Bob
and I say, I can't.
He's, after all, in
the middle there,
and it's not so easy to get--
so Bob started out complaining.
He said, what do you want?
And I started laughing.
So the two of us
just blurted out.
And you see this is
Louis Ignarro, one
of the physiology prize winners.
And he looks around.
He's just totally
flabbergasted at how poorly--
how badly physicists can
behave in front of the kings.
Well, of course, I
mean, it was that one
that ended up in the
newspaper the next day.
My fellow countrymen have
had good fun with me.
Because, in fact,
there was always this--
it raises sort of the question,
is he German, or is he not?
Can we can we count him
as one of ours or not?
And this question actually
goes on, and particularly
because my umlaut--
I have an umlaut in my
name, and I dropped it
when I came to this country.
Because a good friend of
mine, Michael Schluter,
who is no more--
but he told me drop you umlaut.
Because A, the typewriter
doesn't have it.
They don't know
what to do with it.
And then the smart guys
put an E afterwards.
So half of them drop the umlaut.
The other half puts
an E after the O.
Then you have appear
twice in the alphabet,
and it's not next to each other.
So I dropped my umlaut.
But, now, of course, they
have found the umlaut again.
And you wouldn't believe,
in the last APS meeting,
I was in twice, once with
and once without umlaut.
But this is what, actually,
somebody from [INAUDIBLE]
sent me the next day in
the mail from Germany.
This was-- this is sort
of the equivalent of the,
I don't know, daily
news probably.
This was the front page of it.
And when I got this in the
mail, my first reaction
is to fly home and
kill my mother.
Because that's me--
[LAUGHTER]
--as a five-year-old
playing Indians and Cowboys.
In Germany, then, of course,
no concept of the whole thing.
But I thought my mother
had given him that picture.
But indeed, they had
shot it off the wall,
because it's hanging together
with my little brother who's
here that they cut out.
It's hanging on the wall in my
life my parents' living room.
In Germany-- this is, here,
referring to the picture
our Nobel laureate.
And then it says under
here, already as a boy,
he built a toy train with
a rocket propulsion, which
is actually-- which is true.
What it doesn't say there.
So in very small letters here--
and, by the way, it
blew up in his hand
and ripped off his thumb,
which is also true.
It was a long time ago.
I have no problem
with this anymore.
But it certainly doesn't show me
as a very good experimentalist.
So it was a little bit off.
Well, enough of the jokes.
Let me try to talk a bit about
the fractional quantum Hall
effect and see how far I get in.
And Dan said that however I
get, he takes the second half.
So I want to talk about
fractional charges
and fractional quantum numbers.
And I want to give you
sort of an impression what
this whole thing about.
The way I judge the audience
is actually that most of you
actually know
everything about it,
and I might as well sit down.
But, after all, you
paid my ticket up here.
So why don't I deliver.
I don't think I have to
say much to this audience
about condensed metaphysics.
But I think-- let
me just, perhaps,
pick up at one point
along this thought.
And that is one of
the big problems
nowadays in condense
metaphysics is
electron-electron correlations,
meaning that electrons
are strongly interacting,
of course, because they
are charged.
And taking into account
the correlation,
the motion between
electrons as it's
forced upon them by the
other electrons around them
is a very difficult problem.
Most of through our
life, we get away
with very crude approximations.
Number one, forget it.
Just don't take it into account.
Twiddle a little bit
around with the math
and with that dispersion
relation, and you're done.
But, in some cases,
electron-electron interaction
is everything.
For example, in
superconductivity,
it's everything, mediated
by phonons there.
And what I want to
show is another case
where electron-electron
interaction is everything.
And it's only electrons this
time around, electrons in 2D
that really show very
strange behavior, indeed.
In fact, the strange
behavior that it shows--
and it's just the pool of
two-dimension electrons,
nothing else, in
a magnetic field.
You get fractional
charges out, which
was, of course, a big surprise.
The new electron quantum
liquids, fractional quantum
numbers, flux--
magnetic flux can be
attached to electrons.
At least, it looks as if it
were attached to electrons.
New particles are popping
up that can sometimes
be fermions and bosons,
depending on what
magnetic fields you have.
Huge magnetic fields, as big
as the ones that you get next
door-- or got next door, and
you still get a good fraction
of them next door--
can apparently disappear, 10
Tesla, or something like that,
a million times the Earth's
magnetic field, disappears.
And the carriers
that you have seem
to be moving along as if
there were no magnetic field.
There's a mass
popping up, which has
nothing to do with the
mass of the electron.
And they may even
superconduct in some sense.
Let me see whether
I get to this,
give you a bit of an impression.
We're working on two-dimensional
electron systems.
And you can create
two-dimensional electron
system, and three-dimensional
worlds are always
at an interface
between-- can you see--
always at an interface
between two things.
So you could do it on
the surface of helium,
and it is being done on
on the surface of anything.
Typically, things are dirty.
This is no comment
about your floor.
It's just dirty, in the
sense microscopically,
that there are dangling bonds
where the electrons get stuck.
So it turns out,
actually, the best way
to make a
two-dimensional electron
system is that the interface
between two things,
between two semiconductors
inside a semiconductor.
The technique to do
this was actually
developed, invented, in the
'70s by Al Cho at Bell Labs.
And it's a high vacuum
evaporation technique.
We basically evaporate
two semiconductors
on top of each other.
And so this is a
high vacuum chamber.
And you evaporate
gallium and arsenic,
gives you one semiconductor.
Gallium and aluminum
and arsenic gives you
another semiconductor.
That's all you need to know.
And you grow it
on the substrate,
which provides a template
so that the atoms go
into the right place.
Otherwise, it's just like
ball bearings, in the sense,
otherwise, it would be random.
So you provided a nice
underlying lattice for it
to grow.
And, as you know, in order
for semiconductors to conduct,
you have to throw
some dirt into it.
You have to doping them.
And, in this case, actually
silicon becomes the doping.
So silicon is the
stuff that gives off
an additional electron
that then can move around
in the material.
The way this looks is like this.
This is about two-inch diameter.
What is dark here--
disregard these things up there.
They actually do
have something to do
with this what Ray brought up.
And that is this cleave
that you overgrow.
This is not import.
It's just this part down here.
This is the wafer.
So they're shiny semiconductors,
look like a silicon wafer,
basically.
And the reason that the black
here is because the background
was black.
But this is a shiny surface of
about 2-inch diameter, which
then has been grown by MBE.
And the important aspect of
this is that you have incredibly
controlled in this E direction.
You can grow these layers
one layer after the other.
So what you see here
in the cross-section
is four layers of
gallium arsenide,
four layers of
aluminum arsenide,
four layers of gallium arsenide.
This is the black
and white stripes.
You have a control.
This was in one atomic layer.
And this is-- so you
form these layers that
fluctuate by not more
than one atomic layer, so
about an angstrom.
So this is the flattest
surfaces that you
can create with a control
of, really, one layer.
You know you can stop at
five, or six, or seven layers.
And this technique that
was developed and invented
in the 1970s we had
then used in order
to make very high mobility
two-dimension electron system.
In three dimensions,
there's sort of a catch-22
when you dope something.
You throw in the
silicon, which gives off
the electron that then moves
through the semiconductor.
But your left with the charged
the impurities of which
the electron then, very
often, bounces off.
So, yes, you introduce carriers.
But you also introduce
a scattering for it.
In 3D, you hardly
can get around it.
In 2D, you can.
Because in 2D, you
can put the electrons
in one layer and the
dirt in the other layer.
And therefore, they
hardly see each other.
And this is the method to do it.
It's called modulation
doping, which
is-- so the green is
one semiconductor.
The blue is the
other semiconductor.
You put the impurities into
the green semiconductor,
and they wander over into
the blue semiconductor,
because there they
find lower energy.
This is a quantum well of
about 100 angstrom thickness.
And the electrons now
can move in this plane.
But they cannot move in this
E direction because they are
tightly confined.
In fact, they are so tightly
confined that quantum mechanics
plays an important role.
They're confined that you
see the first bound state
and the second bound
state, and they're
separated by about, let's
say, 10 millielectron volts.
So quantum mechanics is an
important aspect of this.
If you only have
the lowest state
occupied, and not
the second one,
the electron in the Z direction
has no degree of freedom.
It's just tight.
It cannot do anything.
But it can move in the
x-y plane easily, in fact,
very readily because
it's such a nice plane,
and then the impurities
are away from it.
So you get a very high mobility
two-dimensional electron system
in which the electron can
run for very long distances
before they scatter as anything.
The electron density
is about 10 to the 11,
which makes about an
electron every 300 angstrom,
something like this.
Typically 10 to the 11.
You can vary, but
that's a typical density
that you will find.
Mobility is nowadays
as high as 10 million.
In fact, last week--
no, it was the week before.
Two weeks ago, we had a
record of 23 million mobility,
which is unheard of.
I mean, I'll show you a
little bit more about this.
You may not understand
what mobility means.
But it's a mean-free pass
of about 100 microns.
In fact, 20 million
is about 200 microns.
So the electron travels in this
plane for about 200 microns
without bouncing into anything.
And 200 microns is really big.
It's about the thickness
of your fingernail, which
doesn't look so big.
But on a microscopic scale,
and on a little graphic scale
what we can do nowadays, it
is a huge mean-free pass.
And it's these two-dimensional
electron system,
which then we can regard
as a two-dimensional metal.
They're basically nothing
else but that with a very long
mean-free pass.
So it means that the
lattice behind it
hardly plays any role.
It's like a two-dimension
electron system
just in free space.
Now, this technique was
invented around 1978, something
like this, by these four guys.
And I show it to
you for two reasons.
The one is sort of
a historical picture
in terms of MBE machines.
This is how MBE
machines looked then.
In fact, what you did is
this is a very high vacuum.
These days, you still open
it up, let all the air in,
stuck your sample in,
pumped it out over night.
And the next morning,
you get your growth.
You don't do this anymore,
much cleaner than that.
The people standing around here
is Willy Wiegmann, Art Gossard,
Ray Dingle, and this is me
in an earlier incarnation,
standing around the MBE
machine for the photographer.
And the important part--
the other important part why I'm
showing to you is Art Gossard.
Art Gossard was the
person that grew
the sample on which
we then discovered
the fractional
quantum Hall effect.
And this was the
first time mobilities
went as high as 90,000.
And that made it all possible.
I mean, it brought
it actually about.
So the sample is the
most important ingredient
to all of this.
And Art Gossard and his
assistant, Billy Wiegmann,
they grew the sample.
And it's really unfortunate
that they didn't
share with us in that prize.
They shared with us in
some previous prizes,
but not in this one.
And I say it's
unfortunate, because I
think for us condensed
metaphysicists,
materials is just the most
important aspect of our work.
The people that have
first hand on materials
are the ones that very often
are ahead in the science
that they're doing because
it's really the materials that
get them to this initial
step from where you then
can start playing.
So Art and MBE technology
is a very important aspect
of all of this.
So what you end up with then is
a two-dimension electron system
where by the separation of
electrons from the doping
impurities and then the
suppression of scattering from
those--
is there any kind of a pointer?
No?
All right.
You get very high mobilities.
At very low temperatures, they
get a very long mean-free pass.
So it looks a bit
like a billiard table
in two dimensions.
Electrons can only
move into two--
Oh, there is one.
Right.
I should-- oh, this is
this little guy there.
Great.
Thanks, Marc.
Let me show you how an
MBE machine looks nowadays
and the people that
are running it.
This is the crew nowadays that
is making this 25 million--
23 million mobility sample.
Actually, the most important
guy, Loren Pfeiffer,
and his assistant Ken West.
This is Kirk Baldwin,
who's an assistant with me.
And this is Amir Yacoby, who
was a post-doc at the time.
So now, the MBE machine
is about that thick.
And you use much
cleaner methods in order
to get such high mobility.
But again, these are
the important guys
to which we owe everything.
I'm very often being
asked, why at Bell Labs?
Why at fraction of charges?
Is it ever going to be
in the telephone system?
And my only answer to
this is this is only
going to make our vacuum
cleaners run only 1/3 speed,
and that's about all.
And it's a joke.
So fractional charges
will not have--
I don't see fractional charges
having any kind of application,
even in the long run.
But there's another
aspect of all
of this work, which
has an application,
and that's this one.
Out of exactly the
same material--
or exactly the same material
in which we discovered,
Dan and I discovered the
fractional quantum Hall
effect--
out of the same
material, you can
make field effect transistors.
It just looks like it.
This is what is in every PC.
It's a MOSFET.
Never mind what it is.
This thing just looks the same.
But it's another material,
and this specific technique
of modulation doping
creates mobilities
that are much higher than here.
And contact resistance
are lower in all of this.
So these transistors,
or transistors
made out of this
materials are the fastest
and lowest noise transistors
in the world still today.
This is one built by
Fujitsu, who actually
was one of the first that made
a microscopic transistor out
of this.
Never mind what
the structure is.
But this is the fastest,
lowest noise transistor
that you can get.
And it's in any of
those around the world.
Each one has one of
those, radio telescopes.
This is not a very big market.
There's just about probably
100 or 200 around the world.
So you cannot make
money with that.
But you can make quite a lot
of money with these things.
So a lot of these high frequency
2 gigahertz telephones that--
cellular phones-- have in the
front end, which is-- well,
the microphone is a
front-end maybe up there--
have one of these
HEM transistors
for very good performance.
And the base stations
have it in there.
So there's another
part of this modulation
doping, which is
not basic science,
but, really, technology.
And I feel very fortunate
that on one side
this is modulation
doping that we invented
led to very basic science.
And on the other side, it
also led to an application.
And it's not so that the
one came after the other.
I think it's an
important lesson.
And we're not the first to
teach this lesson, in a sense.
Or the material is not the
first to teach this lesson, that
is that it's not always an
invention, fundamental physics,
and then there is application.
Very often, these
things go in parallel,
and very often, actually,
they go backwards,
because the progress
in technology
is so important for us to do
the next step in science too.
OK.
Let's get a little bit closer
to the fraction quantum Hall
effect.
If you have such a system,
particularly if it's
semiconductors,
the easiest thing
you can do apart from
measuring its resistance
is to measure the
Hall resistance.
All it is it's like a
resistance measurement,
but in addition, you
put a magnetic field up.
So this is a two-dimension
electron system.
You run a current down it,
and you put a magnetic field
onto it.
Then you measure two
characteristic voltages,
the one is along
the current path.
The other one is across
The one is nothing else
but the resistance,
and the other one should
be 0, as long as there's
no magnetic field because
the thing is symmetric.
But when you put a
magnetic field on it,
then you push the carriers to
one side because of the Lorentz
force.
So you build up a voltage.
Eventually, you'll build
up a voltage from one side
to the other.
That's what you measure.
And these-- the voltage
that you measure--
divided by the current, because
it's proportional to it.
So if you double the current,
you get double the voltage.
So you normalize
it to the current.
You get a resistance, of
characteristic resistance,
which is called the
Hall resistance.
And as Edwin Hall has
already figured out
in the last century, I'll show
this next the next few graph,
Rxy, this resistance
is proportional to E,
to the magnetic
field, and inversely
proportional to the carrier
density in the material.
So it's a wonderful way of
measuring carrier densities
in material, particularly
in semiconductors.
Because, you see, the
smaller end, the easier
it is to measure.
The smaller end, the
bigger this number is.
And typically,
carrier concentrations
are small in semiconductor
as compared to metals.
So this is a wonderful
way of measuring
carrier concentration.
And it's an industry standard.
So this is the
first thing you do.
And we've done this, of
course, but Edwin Hall
had done this already
in the last century.
This is why it's
called Hall effect.
He was a graduate
student, by the way,
at Johns Hopkins in 1879,
when he discovered that
in a very thin foil of gold.
He just did this experiment
that I showed you.
And this is the result here.
In fact, there's
another aspect to all
of this, which I always
enjoy, is for all of us that
are writing papers that
have to be 3 and 1/2 page
and not any longer.
It's interesting to read
this introduction here.
We have to fight with every
word, take it word out,
and make an acronym out of it,
so that you save another five
words.
This starts out with, "Sometimes
during the last university
year, while I was
reading Maxwell's
Electricity and Magnetism--"
I mean, by that time,
you had already--
we're already over your
page limit nowadays.
The other aspect is,
just like it is expensive
nowadays to publish
color figures,
it must have been
expensive in those days
to publish any kind of a figure.
So his results are here
only in form of a table.
So I had to sit down
and, for the first time,
plot up Edwin Hall's data.
And here is Edwin Hall's
data now on a graph.
He has plotted.
This is what we call
nowadays the Hall resistance.
It's actually a current
through the gold leaf
divided by the current
through a magnetometer
versus magnetic field in units
of the Earth's magnetism.
One does not know
what these units are,
but one knows that
it's proportional
to the magnetic field.
So that's fine.
So this is magnetic field.
This is Hall resistance.
And you see, those are his data.
It's a very nice straight
line, just as we know.
And, of course, since
then, this experiment
has been done in many
ways by many people,
and it's a perfectly
nice straight line.
And the slope of this line here
gives you the carrier density
of the material.
The steeper it is, the
less carriers are in it.
So this was a status until
1980 when Klaus von Klitzing
came along and told us
that this is not so at all.
In fact, in two dimensions,
it's not so at all.
This is the original
result, Klitzing, Pepper,
and Dorda in 1980.
And it's plotted in a
different way Edwin Hall would
have plotted it.
So I show you the way--
similar data.
It's not the same
data, but similar data
locks if you plot it like
Edwin Hall plotted it.
Magnetic field Hall resistance.
This is the Hall resistance.
I'll talk about the
other one in a second.
So Edwin Hall would have told
us this is a straight line.
And so Klaus von
Klitzing found--
of course, this is
a very nice example.
The steps were much
weaker when he saw him.
But there are lots
of steps in there.
This is not all a straight line.
These steps are in there.
And not only are these steps
very flat and sometimes very
wide, but they are also
quantized to units of H
over E squared to an accuracy,
nowadays, of a few parts and 10
to the 8.
So a few parts in
a billion, almost,
a few 10 billionths accurately
quantized to this ratio
of natural constant.
This came as a big surprise.
In fact, there are some inklings
in the theoretical literature
that sort of foresaw
this in some sense,
but not really pointed it out.
You experimentalists
should-- and it was obscure.
But Klaus von Klitzing
discovered this, actually,
at the Magnet Lab in
Grenoble, the sort of sister
institution in Europe.
So this is not all
a straight line.
But it's plateaus
and it's quantized.
And I show you also
what the resistance
does as a function
of magnetic field.
That's the other property.
It looks like the
derivative of this.
So whenever this is flat,
it's actually a deep minimum.
And then when it
makes a transition,
you get a spike out of it.
So the magnetic resistance
looks like the derivative
of the Hall resistance.
I show you this
because, later I've
sometimes show you these
data, because they're
sort of more dramatic than
even the Hall resistance.
But it's the same--
the origin is it
has the same origin.
Here comes my two view
graphs explanation
of the integer
quantum Hall effect.
If you put a magnetic field on
a two-dimensional electron gas,
than the electrons classically
perform rotary motion
around the magnetic fields.
So quantum mechanically, this
is just a harmonic oscillator,
so this is my quantum
mechanical oscillator.
And then there are
bound states in there.
And there's only a certain
number of bound-- well,
there's an infinite
number actually.
But they are discrete, and
there's nothing in between.
So the electron can be in
this state, in this state,
or in this state, and
nothing in between.
So in a three-dimensional
electron gas,
there is actually
something in between.
But in 2D, there's
nothing in between.
And therefore, there's
only allowed states
at this energy, at this
energy, and this energy,
and nothing in between.
I forget the spin, or leave the
spin out for most of my talk.
It's just complicates
matters here,
but it's very easy
to take into account.
The other aspect of
this quantization
is that the number
of electrons you
can fit into a squared per
one of these Landau levels,
as they are called,
is only a ratio
of a natural constant
in proportion
to the magnetic field.
So you take-- if you
take this wave function,
it makes sort of
a size out of it.
You take a cookie
cutter and just cut out,
see how many fit in there.
And you see that the number
of electrons per level
is just e times B over h.
And it's independent
of the mass.
It's independent of
epsilon of the materials,
independent of everything.
It's eB, only proportional
to the magnetic field.
So the integral quantum
Hall effect actually
happens when I fill up an
exact number of these states,
of these Landau levels.
And you can see
that very easily.
You take the number of electrons
per level, which is eB over h.
Then if i, 1, 2, 3, 4 of
these levels is filled,
then it's just i times d.
You put this into the
equation that I showed you
earlier that Edwin Hall derived
already in the last century,
and you get the result,
h divided by ie squared.
So it's really true.
There's a big but here.
And this took ingenious
people to figure out.
Because what you
assume in there is
that the number of electrons, in
a certain sense, is quantized,
and that the system is ideal.
You do it here.
But it's never like this,
the number of electrons
is fixed once and for all.
And you never have
an exact number
of Landau levels occupied
except for singular points.
So all this says
is that the long--
right, this is my Hall line here
along the magnetic field line.
There's a few discrete points.
But when I go up,
this resistance
is exactly this number.
But it doesn't say that
there's any plateaus.
I wouldn't even
know where they are.
So this is a bit of a
fake doing this way.
But I cannot go
much deeper into it.
What it tells you is
that this connection
between the quantization
of the Hall resistance
and the two-dimensional system,
the two-dimension electron
system has something
to do with filling up
exact numbers of Landau levels.
And this big but here has
to do with localization
in two dimensions.
There's actually an
important aspect.
If you had an ideal
two-dimension system,
you would not see
the quantum effect.
It requires dirt
in order to see it.
I think it's this sort of
totally counterintuitive.
You need dirt.
You need impurities.
You need localization of
electrons in order to see it.
In fact, the guy
that figured it out
is going to give a
talk sometime today.
This is the--
I will not go through
this argument, of course.
But the bottom line
off of Bob's argument,
one way at least of looking
at it, is that Rxy, this--
you can actually regard it--
which is this number--
you can actually regard it
as a ratio of flux,
of magnetic flux,
quantum to the
electronic charge.
So it's the ratio of flux
quantum to electronic charge.
And therefore, you can look at
this, the quantum Hall effect,
if you turn this
argument around,
as being a measure of e.
So that is a very
accurate measurement
of the electronic
charge, which is then
the flux quantum divided
by whatever you measure.
And then this is an integer.
And the integer you always know
whether it's 1, 2, 3, or 4.
You cannot be that far off.
So it is one way of looking
at the integer quantum Hall
effect that is a very
accurate measurement
of the electronic charge.
The other aspect that I
always found perplexing
is that you measure something
to an accuracy of a few parts
10 to the 8 in a sample that
looks as terrible as that one.
This is about three millimeters
wide, about 15 millimeter long.
This is indium here that
is put on and diffused
in order to make contact.
The black part is actually the
surface of the semiconductor,
which is really shiny.
These parts have
been scratched away
with an ultrasonic scratcher,
really a very intrusive method.
And those are gold
wires running off here.
This is a sample that
was made by Dan Tsui.
I would have done
a much nicer job,
but I'm sure that my contacts
wouldn't have worked.
Dan's worked.
And, in fact, that's
the sample in which
we discovered the fractional
quantum Hall effect.
So in terms of the integral
quantum Hall effect already,
it is always so amazing
that, independent
of geometry, independent of
how you put your contacts on,
you measure something, a
quantity to a few parts 10
to the 8.
And, of course, this is
the essence of a standard,
that it does not depend
on, in this case,
on the geometry at all.
You can even make a round
sample with all the contacts
on the edges.
As long as you do that,
you also measure it.
This is a picture
that's probably
going to bring some emotions
up in some of the people that
are sitting here in the
audience, certainly, Larry,
I would think.
This is-- I don't
know which cell it is,
but Larry can tell us.
Which cell is it, Larry?
It was downstairs
someplace, yeah, I think so.
This is 23 Tesla, I suppose.
Picture that was shot much
later, dilution refrigerator--
that's the fridge.
This is the can for around it.
This is the pumping system.
A person is about as big
as this pumping system.
And we went with samples
through the Magnet Lab
and did experiments in
high magnetic fields,
and later on then with
a dilution refrigerator.
This is about 10 years
later, I would think,
but still when the Francis
Bitter National Magnet
Lab was in--
up here.
Well, it still is up here,
only without the National.
Dan and I were coming up
here for several years
to do experiments.
And we were typically getting
up on Sunday morning, driving up
here, having a long
four-hour chat.
Depending on who
was driving, it was
either three or four hours--
four or five, I
should say, I think.
We're not that fast.
And we had this brand new
sample form Art Gossard.
We were doing experiments
down in whatever cell.
I don't know which cell it was.
We were working on
silicon MOSFETs, actually.
Dan had invited me
to come up with him.
He was there already since
quite a while doing experiments
on silicon.
And then with this
new sample, we
started working together on
this modulation dopes systems.
So here's the result
of October, 6, 1981.
This is the Hall resistance.
This is the magnetic
field, just what
Edwin Hall would have done.
And it's a very
nice straight line.
This is an offset here,
so they get it still
on the chart recorder paper.
It's an old technology
to take data.
You take a pen and pull
it over a piece of paper.
And then you look at the trace.
And that's what
your data is like.
There is-- actually,
this is my handwriting--
this says laser upstairs.
You see these spikes here?
There was-- I don't
know which laser.
There was a powerful
laser upstairs,
and whenever they yanked it,
we got a big signal down there.
So this is from
the laser upstairs.
We just had to make sure
that this was not physics,
but just a third effect.
But otherwise, it's just
a nice straight line,
just as Edwin Hall
would have said.
But they're already
deviations coming up here.
And these deviations are from
the integral quantum Hall
effect.
We knew exactly where they
were, where they had to be.
So the top line is
basically a repetition
of this, taken at 4 degrees.
And when we pumped lower, to
lower temperatures, indeed,
these structures became
nice flat Hall plateaus.
And that was the
last Hall plateau,
on the second last Hall plateau.
Everything, all the
world was in order.
But it got out of order up here.
What you see here is that the
magnetic field is about three
times as high as this one.
Remember, this is the
last Hall plateau.
This is the last time
the Fermi energy can
be between two Landau levels.
From then on, it's always
in the lowest Landau level.
So there was nothing
expected out here.
Actually, I should
say, the reason
we looked at these things was
because Dan Tsui at the time
wanted to look at
the Wigner lattice.
He had done that
already in silicon.
And we thought, well, let's
look at these materials
and see where the
Wigner lattice.
The Wigner lattice is this
when the electron condense
into a regular
array of electrons,
a hexagonal array, or
triangular lattice-- triangular,
I should say.
It's not hexagonal--
triangular lattice
of electrons that
become immobilized
and they form a nice
two-dimensional lattice.
This was a prediction back then.
There are now some
indications over the years
that something like
that indeed exists.
And that's what we
were looking for.
And what we saw is
this plateau there.
Well, it's not a plateau yet.
But it's sort of a
inflection point.
We got all excited about it.
But, of course, it could
be all sort of things.
I mean, samples, resistances
very often shot up
or shot down.
But this one looked
sort of clean up here,
but then it
developed this thing,
which just looks like
the integral quantum Hall
effect at a higher temperature,
but at a different point.
And we were standing there
down in whatever cell floor.
And in about 15 seconds,
Dan did the following.
And I always tell this, because
I think it's just wonderful
and tells you a
lot about Dan Tsui.
He took this into his finger,
the distance from here to here.
And he counted off how
often he could count it off
until it got to
this magnetic field.
So it was 1, 2, 3.
And he said 1, 2, 3 quarks.
And we both had a very
good chuckle about it,
because it was so humorous that,
of course, quarks, of course,
are elementary particles
with which a charge of 1/3
is associated.
And, of course, we are not doing
elementary particle physics.
The highest voltage we
have applied in our system
is about 10 millielectron volts.
So this is a small m.
This is not a capital M.
And it's certainly not a G.
So it was a good joke.
But, at the same time,
he was dead right.
Because that it had something
to do with the charge of 1/3
really turned out to be correct.
And that just shows you
tremendous insight of Dan.
So this is then--
this is the argument
written out.
If you take Bob
Laughlin's argument
at the time, which is that
the electronic charge,
or whatever you measure,
is just the flux quantum
divided by this.
And you take it seriously,
that's what you get out.
Just put the numbers in, and
this is just this 1, 2, 3.
It's 1/3 of an electronic
charge somehow involved
if you take it literally.
So, of course, at the
time, it wasn't clear
whether it was
really a step or not.
After all, it was only
a slight inflection.
It was only an inflection here.
So the question was whether
it was a step or not.
And we had to look closely
whether it actually was a step.
You see this says here,
this is not a step.
[LAUGHTER]
I often show-- I often
show this view graph.
And I do it nowadays in
different continents.
This is the only one
that can laugh about it.
You go to Europe, they just--
there's just dead silence.
They don't get this joke.
And you know why not.
This country is run by lawyers.
So going to lower temperatures,
what was an inflection point
really became a
pretty nice plateau.
And I always say is a
few parts and 10 to the 4
that this was at 1/3,
and it was quantized
to about 3 times H over e--
so H over 1/3 e squared,
I should probably put it.
And simultaneously,
the resistance,
the magnetoresistance, actually
developed a deep minimum,
which wasn't going
yet all the way down.
But it looked like it.
As a function of temperature,
it was going down.
Another picture of the
time a little bit later,
down that was now around the
hybrid magnet is this one.
This was taken in February 16,
1984, about three years later.
But it's the only
one that I got.
And those were people
that were working with us.
This is Albert Chang.
This is Peter Berglund,
Greg Boebinger, Dan Tsui,
and myself here
holding up a sign.
85 millikelvin, 80 kilogauss.
Peter Berglund was the guy
that developed this and built
this dilution refrigerator
that's sitting down here.
And there was a post-doc
on a grad student, actually
an MIT grad student, that
Peter Wolff told us about.
Peter said, I got a
good grad student.
You want one?
And we said, sure.
And Greg just became a
terrific collaborator.
He's nowadays director of
the Magnet Lab at Los Alamos.
There's one section
that's in Los Alamos,
and Greg is running this now.
So he's still sticking to
magnets, like most of us.
We fell in love with magnets.
Cannot get away from them.
Must have something to do
with the attractive force.
So it very quickly became
clear that different
from the integral
quantum Hall effect--
and you'll have seen
all this, so I'm not
going to go through it.
There was the argument that the
fraction quantum Hall effect is
not a single particle effect.
It does not come about from
the interaction between--
sorry-- from the quantization
of individual electrons
in the presence of an
electric magnetic field
in a semiconductor.
But it had to do with
interaction between electrons.
It must come from this,
because all of the steps that
come about from individual--
quantization of
individual electrons
were all expressed in the
integer quantum Hall effect
already.
There shouldn't
be anything else.
And there were, I think,
the smartest and brightest
of the theorists who were
trying to figure it out
for quite a while.
And this here is Bob.
And he says, "Nothing yet.
How about you, Newton?"
With an apple from hell
about to drop onto him.
And, of course, you're
going to hear more about it.
But this is what
he came up with.
This is his wave function.
And I'm always--
I always express that I find
this an immense achievement
that the behavior
of some 10 to the 11
electrons you can
describe everything
with an equation that has
just about 15 digits in them,
15 letters in them.
This is Bob Laughlin's
wave function.
He's going to tell
us more about it.
But this is the solution.
This is, within
quantum mechanics,
everything we can know about it,
including all the interactions
between the electrons.
Bob will modify that, I suppose.
Let me tell you about
the fraction quantum Hall
effect and its origin from
a slightly different point
of view that we have developed
over the-- when I say we,
the theorists have.
And I'm just a few--
a poor interpretation
of the theorists' work.
One way of looking at the
fraction of quantum Hall effect
nowadays is from
the point of view
of the attachment
of magnetic flux
to the electrons,
which is driven
by electron-electron
interaction.
The electrons try to
be at the position
where there's no other electron.
They have to do that for
Pauli principle reasons.
But the more you get the
electrons away from you,
the better it is for Coulomb
reason because of the Coulomb
interaction with
the other electrons.
So since the wave
function have 0s,
many particles may
function as also 0s.
They try to attract as many 0s
of the wave function onto them.
It is advantageous
in terms of energy.
And one way of
describing that is
in terms of what's
called [INAUDIBLE] flux.
It's similar as if you had
attached to the electrons
a magnetic flux.
I won't go any
further into this.
It takes theorists to do it,
and certainly much more time.
But then this
particle statistics
is actually changing.
If you take two electrons,
you change them around.
And their fermions, the
wave function gets a minus 1
in front.
So they're fermions.
If you take two electrons
with a vortex attached-- well,
with a [INAUDIBLE]
flux-- let's just
call it magnetic flux-- attached
to them, you exchange them,
you get also this minus sign.
But because there's
a magnetic field
and you move the electrons
around the magnetic field
that's stuck to
the other electron,
it gets an additional
phase change.
And therefore, the minus 1 is
multiplied by another minus 1,
so it's a plus 1.
If you stick 2 on it, it
becomes a minus 1 again.
If you take 3, it
becomes a plus 1.
So these behave like fermions.
These behave like bosons.
These behave like fermions.
These behave-- in fact,
whenever m is odd,
it looks like a boson.
And whenever m is even,
it looks like a fermion.
And there's a long
list of people--
I couldn't list
everybody on here--
a long list of people
that, over time,
have developed this picture.
So there's a way, which
I call here another way--
because I don't have
the time to show the--
and Bob is going to
speak later anyway.
So one way of looking at the
fractional quantum Hall effect
at 1/3 then is to
take electrons.
Imagine there are 3 flux quanta
attached to them by virtue
of the electron-electron
interaction, which
forces them to have 0s
on the wave function.
But just look at that as being
magnetic flux attached to them.
Then I look at these
particles as new particles,
which are no longer
fermions but bosons now.
And these new particles now
are green little spheres
rather than red little spheres
with three arrows on them.
So I have now a system
of green little balls.
And the red balls
plus flux quanta
have been transformed
into these green balls.
And they are now bosons
rather than the electrons.
In the magnetic
field, actually, they
become bosons in
no magnetic field,
because all of
the magnetic field
has been sucked in
by the electrons.
They're attached
to the electrons.
They don't see the
magnetic fields anymore.
This is sort of a
jump that I'm making.
You have to really think
more deeply about it,
particularly since I'm seeing
it's [INAUDIBLE] flux, not
real flux.
There are deep
issues down there.
But just for the
purpose of this talk,
we take the electron with three
flux quanta attached to them
and make out of them
what's now called
composite bosons in the
absence of magnetic field.
Then you have a
system, a new system,
of composite bosons where the
magnetic flux has disappeared.
And this system then
is at 0 magnetic field.
And bosons condense into the
bose condensate superficially,
certainly.
And, indeed, that's
one of the way
you can look at the 1/3
state, that you do this,
take the electrons, put flux
quanta, make new particles,
and bosons in 0
magnetic field, and they
condense into a bose
condensate, and that's
what the 1/3 state is.
So you can look at it
as a bose compensation
of composite bosons.
This is, actually,
historically backwards but.
It's pedagogically a little
bit easier to do it this way.
Now, that's the 1/3 state.
How about all
these other states?
And there's a slew of them.
The 1/3 was just the first.
And then there are tons of
other states that came about.
And here, I show you what is
the magnetoresistance, which
looks like the derivative
because it's more impressive.
And I apologize,
actually, for the picture
because it's old by now.
In the meantime,
there's probably 5,
6 more oscillations here.
So there's 1/3, 2/5 3/7,
4/9, 5/11, 6/13, 7--
whatever-- up to 21.
So you see all these other--
the integer quantum Hall effect
are these deep minima here.
All the rest is fractions.
It's not just the 1/3.
It's just a slew of
things, of fractions.
This is a list of fractions
that have been seen.
We can argue about
to what degree we
trust each of these fractions.
But this is just my
way of writing it down.
I say this one is OK.
And, I think,
actually, recently,
we just have seen something
that looks like 6/23.
So it's up here.
See, it's a slew of
fractions, not just one third.
It was just the first
one to be discovered.
So what's the origin of this?
OK, so it makes it a little
bit busy that suddenly all
of these fractions--
A little bit like
these chaps here.
There's a guy reading
the music down here.
And you say, gee, look at
all these little black dots.
It's totally confusing
what's happening there.
The first thing when
I was looking into--
and it's this state at 1/2.
See, there's something at 1/2.
It doesn't look at all
like these other fraction
that have this nice minima.
The 1/2 state is a
broad little thing.
It doesn't do much as a
function of temperature.
This is a low temperature of 100
millikelvin, 123 millikelvin,
perhaps.
It doesn't do much.
It just sits there.
And the 1/2 state was for
long a long time a miracle,
sort of, what this
thing is all about.
But then when I heard
the description of it--
and the people that are most
responsible for it-- actually,
these few here.
But then, also, Jainendra
Jain, who actually-- again,
this is historically backwards.
I'll get to it.
So in the same vein of what I
told you about electrons flux
quanta onto it, you can
then look at the 1/2 state
where there's only
two flux per electron.
You attach those to it.
And as I told you earlier, now,
they look like fermions again.
But they look like fermions
without a magnetic field,
or the magnetic fluxes
on the electrons.
And therefore, you get now
pink particles, pink particles
that behave like fermions,
but in the absence
of a magnetic field.
And therefore, the magnetic
field has been eaten up.
The electrons are moving around
just like in 0 magnetic field.
But they're fermions.
Not but they're fermions.
They remain fermions
in spite of the fact
that two flux have attached to
them, or just because actually.
We know what a system that is
fermions in 0 magnetic field
does.
It fills up a Fermi surface.
That is exactly, actually, what
was found and was predicted
first, but then was
found experimentally
in various experiments
by Bob Laughlin-- sorry,
I wanted to say Bob Willard.
Bob Laughlin has just become an
experimentalist, what he always
wanted to be in life.
So I made you one.
This is just a caricature,
just a cartoon of it.
So you find it in
k space, a circle
like that, the Fermi edge.
And you can measure this.
Never mind the fact of 2.
In fact, this fact-- this
difference of fact of 2,
actually, square root of
two was an important aspect
of that, yes, this
really looks like it.
So this was found that
the electrons at 1/2
form a new Fermi surface,
just like in 0 magnetic field.
And then you-- OK,
so we have only 1/2.
So what of all the
other fractions?
In all the other fractions then,
one can look at in this way.
And that's really,
historically, sort
of the starting point of it.
But for this talk,
better to do this way.
You remember this view graph.
That was one of the very first
view graphs I showed you.
Just integral quantum
Hall effect, quantization.
This is the 2D surface,
quantized Hall--
Landau levels, et cetera.
And then one thinks of
all these other states
in a way that is analogous to
the fractional quantum Hall
state--
sorry, to the integer
quantum Hall state.
See, the integer quantum
Hall state is down here,
and you get these oscillations
from the integer Hall effect.
Now we have another 0 of
magnetic field, so to say,
at 1/2, where all the magnetic
field has been eaten up.
And if I slightly change
the magnetic field,
then I get a residual
magnetic field.
And these particles
here that see
0 magnetic field is
actually exactly 1/2,
see a finite magnetic field
if you get a little bit off.
And then they develop
Landau levels.
Just like the electrons develop
Landau levels down here,
these new particles,
composite fermions,
develop Landau
levels by themselves.
And these Landau levels
of the composite fermions
become the fractional
quantum Hall states.
So you can look at the
fractional quantum Hall
effect also as the
integral quantum effects,
but not of regular electrons,
but of composite fermions.
And there's a very
nice symmetry.
This is just the same
plot only, one's in red
and one's in black.
And if I pull this
over here, where
I put the 1/2 on top
of the 0, then you
see that the black minima, which
are from the fractional quantum
Hall effect, and the
red minima, which
were from the integral
quantum Hall effect,
are just on top of each other.
So we should have seen
this experimentally.
But it was really
the theorists that
were pushing down our throat.
I suppose I have
about two minutes.
Is this correct?
OK.
So this picture is now
confirmed in many ways.
There have been experiments done
on these fractional states that
then let you extrapolate back to
some kind of a mess around 1/2.
There's a lot of questions
still associated what's
happening exactly at 1/2.
What is the mass?
What does it really mean?
What kind of phenomena
do you see there exactly?
What else could you see?
Is it a real Fermi
system or not?
These are all things that
are up in the air and still
experiments being done on it.
But the concept of a composite
fermion, composite boson
is really something that
has become very important
in the fractional
quantum Hall effect.
The spin of the electron
also has back in
and became a very
important tool to measure
some of the energy gaps.
I don't have time
to get into it.
We can actually associate a mass
with these composite fermions.
We can associate a G factor
with the composite fermions.
All this has been done
over the past few years.
Let me show you just one other
state that is of great interest
nowadays.
And that's a state
out here, at 5/2.
Never mind how I get to this.
This is the 1/2.
This is the 3/2.
This guy is called 5/2.
It basically means, for
every five flux quanta,
you get 2 electrons.
And this state looks
sort of like this one.
But when you cool-- this state
looks sort of like this one.
But when you cool
it down, it doesn't.
And this is the newest
experiments on that.
When you cool the 5/2 state
down-- sorry, it's a bit busy--
it goes to 0, and
it gets a plateau.
Now, this is a 1/2 state, so
it has an even denominator.
So it should be a fermion,
and fermions do not
show a fractional
quantum Hall effect.
Composite fermions do not show a
fractional quantum Hall effect,
but they show a Fermi surface.
This one shows a fractional
quantum Hall effect.
It was discovered in '87, I
think, Bob Willard, et al.
And that was a big surprise,
an even denominator
became a fractional
quantum Hall effect.
How come?
We still don't know.
Well, let me actually point out.
This is the lowest temperature
ever have cooled down
in an electron system.
These data were just taken
at the Magnet Lab in--
Talla-- sorry, not Tallahassee--
Gainesville-- where they have
very low temperatures, milli--
microkelvin, for that matter.
We use it only
down to millikelvin
in high magnetic fields.
This is not that high, actually.
This is only 3.7 Tesla.
But we were able to cool
the electron system down
to 4 millikelvin, which
is a real achievement--
the elections, not the
lattice-- this is the electron
temperature-- by various
trick that the people
at the Gainesville,
[INAUDIBLE] and then together
with our student
down there, Wei Pan,
developed that really
let us do this.
Now, the speculation-- and
there still is a speculation,
although the theorists
tell us more and more
that they're very
convinced about this.
And they even tell us that
our data is supported.
I don't understand
that argument yet.
Is that what's happening
is just like at 1/2,
the electrons actually
do form fermions.
They take an electron,
put 2 flux quanta onto it,
and they are fermions.
So now we have b equal
to 0 with new fermions
called composite fermions.
But then they discover that they
can actually mutually attract
pairwise.
This is an interaction
in real space.
But, in fact, the
wave function that you
can write down for it--
it's called a pfaffian.
I'm way out of my league here,
but it's called a pfaffian.
But it looks similar to BCS wave
function with an l equal to one
in there.
But there is an interaction
in there, and they form pairs.
And these pairs-- sort of in
far analogy with Cooper pairs,
if you think of it--
they can condense.
They form a new
quantum liquid now.
So you form first fermions.
Then you have an
interaction which is just
all Coulomb interaction.
And they form pairs,
and these pairs then
open up a new gap,
which is something
like a superconducting gap.
So in a sense, they form a new
kind of superconductor made out
of composite
fermions, and that's
what you see in the experiment.
Let me leave it at that.
There are various other
experiments that are very--
other parts of the
magnetic field scale.
There are, nowadays,
anisotropies
that are being discovered
in high magnetic fields.
They're called stripe phases.
There is the
question, for example,
how many electrons
are required in order
to see the fractional
quantum Hall effect?
Obviously, one is
not good enough.
I say obviously, but this
is an important part.
One is not good enough.
It's a many particle effect.
And some people
like Ray and others
are looking whether 3 is
enough or 5 is enough,
or do you need 10
in order to see it.
There's a Wigner
solid out there where
electrons are
supposed to condense
into a solid of electrons.
And that one, there
are indications for it.
There are things
called skyrmions,
which are many particle
spin systems that
are playing a role.
So this field is alive and
well, to say the least.
I believe the 5/2 state, if
we really can pin it down,
that at this kind
of a state, it's
really opening up a whole
new universe of experiments
that can be done.
Let me show you my
last view graph,
and that is sort of
where are we going.
This is the data, or the
result that Edwin Hall gave us
about 100 years ago.
Magnetic field, Hall
effect, straight line.
So this is just the
standard Hall effect.
Then Klaus von Klitzing
came along and told us
that this is not so.
There's actually-- you see
this is a used view graph.
I better fix it up.
There's these big steps in here.
This is the integral
quantum Hall effect.
And then Dan and I were so
lucky to discover the 1/3 state.
So suddenly, there
were more steps here.
And then, the 5 something
came along, and the 7, and 11,
and the 13, and
the 17, and the 23.
And as we keep
going, we're going
to end up with that, which
is a perfectly straight line.
Only what you don't see is
that there are infinitely
many steps along here.
It's called the
Devil's staircase,
Devil for obvious reasons.
And it's going to be
fractions all over the place.
So eventually, we're going to
end up just like Edwin Hall,
and he's going to tell
us, I told you so.
So let me just show you
this graph here, which
is probably the most important.
All of this--
I only change pump oil.
Of course, Dan,
who's going to talk,
long friend and
collaborator and, really,
my mentor in many ways.
Lots of collaborators,
post-docs,
students at Bell
Labs that have worked
on the fractional
quantum Hall effect.
And then there is
particularly the people
that are the crystal growers
that are here pointed out in--
all important ones here in red,
Art Gossard and Willy Wiegmann,
and then also Loren
Pfeiffer and Ken West
who are growing the
samples nowadays.
So it was these people working
on the fractional quantum Hall
effect that really
brought it all about.
I always feel that
Dan and I, we were
so lucky to discover-- it's
a little bit like archeology.
We discovered the
first tile sticking out
from a roof out of
the sand, and then it
was all these terrific people
that continued the work
and really were
cleaning up the whole--
not cleaning up,
actually discovering
the whole building, which
finally made us to receive
the Nobel Prize for it.
I feel like the luckiest
person in the world
having been able to work
with such terrific people
and being part of this endeavor.
So, in a sense, I think I owe
a lot of-- not in a sense,
I do owe a lot of gratitude
to all of these people that
have brought it about.
I feel that I was only
one of the lucky ones that
was just there at the right
time at the right place.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And, of course, the
right place at the time
was sort of one
street down the road.
ASHOORI: Thanks for
a beautiful overview.
You don't get away so soon.
Are there questions?
STORMER: I don't want
to cut into Dan's--
ASHOORI: Marc?
KASTNER: First,
couldn't it have been
done without the Magnet Lab?
STORMER: No.
KASTNER: [INAUDIBLE]
STORMER: Yes, of course.
No, no.
Look, no doubt.
We see the fractional
quantum Hall effect
now at 0.8 kilogauss,
something like this.
So this is exaggerated.
But it's a few kilogauss.
So, yes, of course today.
But at this time, no.
This sample is required.
This sample, which
was 90,000 mobility,
in the field of whatever
it was, 19 Tesla
or something like that
were this is where
the inflection was to see it.
At any lower than that,
it wouldn't have happened.
Nowadays, we have
superconducting magnets
that go that high.
At that point superconducting
magnets were typically 8 Tesla.
So one would not have seen it.
Yes, at that point,
it required the sample
and this magnetic field.
A few years later,
if actually it
had been pursued any
further, maybe people
would have said, well,
forget modulation doping.
It doesn't look interesting.
But a few years later,
you could do it at home,
meaning in a superconducting
magnet, but not at the time.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ASHOORI: - Bob--
AUDIENCE: Of course,
there are two prototypes
I know about for the 1/2.
And they're distinguished,
so you allegedly
can find the edge properties.
STORMER: I what?
AUDIENCE: Edge--
STORMER: Edge state?
AUDIENCE: Are you guys
currently working on--
STORMER: No.
This is-- edge states are
always the next generation.
I mean, you first
have to get the bulk.
Let me not call it bulk.
You first have to get
whatever we are doing,
the trivial stuff, right before
you look into the edge states.
Tunneling into the edge
state is a difficult problem.
You know, I mean,
it's still-- there's
lots of question about
what you really see when
you chiral systems, et cetera.
So I don't have anything.
Maybe Dan is going to
tell you something.
But I think-- no, we don't
have anything on the edge.
You know, the other
thing to differentiate
the two states is whether it's
been polarized or unpolarized.
And that's already
a difficult one.
That's the experiment that
we wanted to do since a year.
But it's so hard to turn
a sample at 4 millikelvin
electron temperature down
in a high magnetic field
and see whether one sees the
lifting of the spin degeneracy.
That, I think, is a
trivial experiment.
Although, it's very hard.
And then comes the edge.
ASHOORI: Why do they call the
5/2 state a superconductor,
when the longitudinal
conductance doesn't-- it goes
to 0?
So it's that--
STORMER: You know why.
I mean, it's-- the analogy with
superconductivity is a long
one.
There's lots of things
that are different.
But since it looks like-- it
has sort of the character of BCS
wave function in there,
so you can look at it
as being superconductivity.
But then, of course,
everything else is different.
Don't catch me at
my weak points.
ASHOORI: Peter?
AUDIENCE: Horst?
STORMER: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Is there anybody
else you can think of
who's sitting here?
STORMER: I don't think so.
I don't think so.
I mean, there is a
description of these states
here, a theoretical description.
I think all the connections
are not yet made.
In fact, it was
theoretically predicted
that there was stripe phases.
Let's also keep in mind there's
a prediction of stripe phases--
something.
And then there are experiments
that are shown anisotropy.
So far, the connection
that the anisotropy
is due to stripe phases
had not really been made.
We just think this is the area
where there is anisotropy.
This is the area where there
should be stripe phase.
Probably, that's what it is.
One doesn't really know that.
What has been discovered
is anisotropy.
But it's probably stripe phases.
From point of theory, I think
we got the experts in here.
What?
AUDIENCE: Almost certainly yes.
STORMER: OK.
This is one--
Patrick?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ASHOORI: So we sit back at
this time in the Magnet Lab
when you came up
with Horst first law
that I teach my
students all the time.
STORMER: Horst first law?
I haven't heard about this.
ASHOORI: That crummiest looking
samples always work best.
STORMER: Oh.
Yeah, I guess I learned
this from Dan in many ways.
ASHOORI: OK.
If there are no more questions,
let's thank Horst again.
[APPLAUSE]
LEE: Well, it is a real pleasure
to welcome Dan Tsui to MIT.
Dan, soon after he got
his PhD from Chicago then
went to Bell Labs, where he
spent about 15 years before he
went to Princeton
University as a professor
in the electrical
engineering department.
I got to know Dan in the '70s
when we were both in Bell Labs.
And, as some of you might
know, especially in those days,
Bell Labs was known for having a
bunch of very aggressive people
around.
Well, there are a few
exceptions to this rule,
and Dan is one of them.
But Dan may not be the
one who walks the fastest
or talks the fastest, but when
it comes to matters that count,
it doesn't take long for one
to figure out that he's usually
the one that gets there first.
I had the experience,
for example,
in the late '70s
when a lot of us
were doing work on the
localization, weak localization
effects, and disorder
effects, and so on.
Dan was really very quick.
He instantly understood the
importance of what's going on,
understood the theory.
And he realized immediately
that the MOSFET system
is the ideal system to
study these new theories,
because you can control
the electron density
and everything else.
So within a matter of a month
or two, he and David Bishop
came up with the experiment,
a definitive experiment that
showed all these weak
localization effects,
and so on.
And, of course, the
next great achievement
was the fractional quantum Hall
effect that we'll hear about.
Since that time, I
came to MIT in '82.
And one of the
great pleasures is
to have periodic visits from Dan
when he comes to do experiments
at the Magnet Lab.
And every time he
would come and he
would show me all
these new data that he
found that he's excited about
that he wants to understand.
But every time I
talk to Dan, I always
come away with the
impression that he's
someone who is really fascinated
by nature, by what he's doing.
He loves being at the frontier
and exploring this new world.
And he is someone who
really wants to understand
what he's studying.
And to him, getting
credit, or being the first,
or getting honor
seems to be secondary.
These are things that would
come naturally for him.
Science is really
what drives them.
And so it's wonderful
that this great honor
has come to someone who
really does not seek it.
And so I present to you Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
TSUI: Thank you, Patrick.
It is an honor and
always a pleasure
to be back on MIT campus.
I think Horst
probably would say--
well, I enjoyed
it so much, I even
spent my first sabbatical
in the Magnet Lab,
in the Francis Bitter
Magnet Lab, which--
which I wanted to,
for the talk, is
to take this opportunity to
have a closer look of some
of the longstanding
problems as characterized
by some of the questions--
some of the questions
and the comments
we used to hear very often.
So more specifically,
what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to give you a very
brief superficial overview,
basically relation
the overall, the other
even-denominator fractions,
which Horst already
touched upon.
But before I go into any
detail, into those experiments,
I'm going to spend some
time to, how you say,
tunneling experiment
into the sample edges.
And I don't think I'll--
or Richard and I
thought I'll also
go through some of the
microwave absorption experiments
in the very small
fractional limit, where
the system, the
electrons are insulating,
are true insulators.
And if you like, it's a belief--
well, it is a punitive
linear crystal regime.
But I probably will not
have time to go into that.
So this is what I
would like to do.
Let me-- I have this
view graph here just
to remind me to say that in our
modern day electronics world,
and mostly, device
functions are performed
by these two-dimensional
electrons, which
confine to move along
the interface of two
different semiconductors, or a
semiconductor and an insulator.
But the only point
I want to make here
is under normal
ambience, these electrons
behaves as just ordinary GaAs
of two-dimensional particles.
The strange, or the
extraordinary physics,
which Horst has shown us becomes
dominant, or very apparent,
when you take a system at
low temperatures exposed
to high magnetic field, and when
the system actually is clean.
It's a clean
two-dimensional system.
That's the point.
But the other point
I want to make
is, really, the only reason
I want to show that view
graph before--
actually, let me put it back.
Because in the magnetic
field, the energy,
or the so-called
Landau quantization
quantizes the energy spectrum
into discrete levels.
If you like, they're massively
degenerate discrete levels.
And these levels are
called Landau levels.
And the point I
want to make here
is mainly the terminology
I want to keep straight.
So the Landau level
index, this big N,
is usually integers 0,
1, 2, 3, large numbers,
you know, whatever numbers.
So when you take the
electron spin into account,
each Landau level composed--
or has two spin levels.
That's the only
point I want to make,
because what we need to
keep in mind to look at some
of the data in some detail.
OK.
We have already heard
from Horst's talk
that in the so-called fractional
quantum Hall effect regime,
correlation is everything.
And the-- for the odd
denominator fractions--
which we know the systems go
into so-called Hall liquids.
At the odd-denominator
quantum Hall liquids,
we have these fractional
states, you have seen.
But also, we have seen there is
the even-denominator fractions.
Correlation favors normal
metal-like Fermi sea
of composite particles,
or the composite Fermions.
And this is the case for
the lowest Landau level,
if you like, the n
equal to 0 Landau level.
And this is the data, actually
from very recent sample,
Loren Pfeiffer and Ken
West grow out in September.
And the data was taken by Wei
Pan, who is graduate student
Horst and I supervised.
And what you notice here,
the filling factor 2
is somewhere here, and down.
So this is for the n
equal to 0 Landau level.
So there will be two spin--
if a spin split, it would
spin up down here somewhere,
and have the spin down here.
OK.
So in this level, indeed,
the composite fermion
is what the ground state for
even denominator fractions
is indicated here.
And, for example, the 1/2,
you have already heard from--
Horst already showed to
you, except in this sample,
because the perfection
of the 2D electron
system, this [INAUDIBLE],,
I think Horst said
is, denominator
21, or 20 whatever.
And here is similarly for 1/4.
And the main thing is for
the even fraction where
the composite fermion
is the ground state,
the structure is
essentially featureless
and is flanked by two series.
In this case, it's
the p over for p
plus minus series of
fractional quantum Hall states.
And here is a p over
2p plus minus 1 series
of fractional Hall states.
And similarly for
the 3/4 and 3/2.
So for the n equal to
0 Landau level, indeed,
the odd-denominator fractions
are the fractional quantum Hall
liquids.
The even-denominator fractions
are these composite fermion
states.
For the higher Landau level--
that's what I want to show
here--
and that, apparently,
is not the case.
The data looks very different.
Again, here is the lowest
Landau level n equal to 0.
You see that the
even-denominator fraction
is essentially featureless.
Just the fractional quantum
Hall states converges unto this.
The fractional
quantum Hall state
is this deep minimum and just
convergence into this even
composite fermion, the ground
state, the composite fermion
gas state, essentially
featureless.
But when you go
to the next Landau
level, and you go to one level--
that's for the 7/2 and 5/2--
and you have deep
minimum, which is
very similar to the
fractional quantum states.
And also, these structures,
you know, on the flanks,
on the sides, those are indeed
the fractional quantum Hall
states.
OK.
Now, when you go to the next
higher level, the index is--
and you could do 2.
And you actually see are
large spikes at the 9/2, 11/2.
And similar for the next level,
and you could do 3, 13/2, 15/2.
These actually have large peaks.
But more importantly,
whether they are a peak
or a minimum, a
very deep minimum,
depends on how you
do the measurement,
depend on the measurement.
The current is measured
in what direction?
The black's measured along
this direction, defined
as x direction, and the
other one is the y direction.
So this is, basically, what--
well, I'm going to do
is I'll come back--
I'll come back to
show you more data,
look at these
higher Landau level.
And you go to 1,
and you go to 2.
And pick-- in particular,
just pick out the 5/2 and 9/2
to go through the
experiment in some detail.
But before I do that,
I want to address,
basically, the
other comments you
have seen about edge states.
Halperin and Wen-- so we got
one probably sitting somewhere
in the audience, I know--
were the first told us how to
think about the sample edges,
how to think about
the edge states.
In case of the integer
quantum Hall effect
is quite easy to visualize
or to picture them.
And that's what is illustrated
on this view graph.
If this is the bulk material,
in a strong magnetic field,
we look at the 1
electron energy levels,
they are just
these Landau levels
separated by an
energy gap, which
is just the cyclotomic energy.
Now, when I go to the surface,
approaching the surface, sample
surface, then when the electron
orbit in the magnet field,
the electron feels the surface
potential, or the surface feel.
Then it changes.
It increases the
electron energy.
So why would my
Landau level would
have to be drawn in this way?
So now if I am at the
integer quantum Hall states--
so my Fermi level is somewhere
between these two levels,
below are all filled.
Top, my n, below
n is all filled.
My n plus 1 is all empty.
Then, of course, inside
the sample in the bulk
is an insulator gapped.
But when come to
the surface, there
is a state right
at the Fermi level.
And these states,
or if you like,
the electrons in
these states are
one one-dimensional
electron system.
And this becomes more clear
in the next view graph.
In the real space, this
is how it would look.
This, of course, you
would recognize this.
This is probably some
graduate student's thesis.
Who else would do
this neat think?
This is taken from
Matt Grayson's thesis.
As a matter of fact, the data
going to show are all from him.
So in the bulk in
quantum Hall effect,
the levels in all these side
for orbits are all occupied.
And the next higher energy
level ones are empty.
It's not shown here.
But come to the
edges, the edge states
are just the so-called, in
metaphysics in the '60s,
we called them the
skipping orbits.
These are the skipping orbits.
And because of the
magnetic field,
they all skip in one direction.
And the language, the
proper language to describe,
a fancier language,
they're a motion of chiral.
They're moving in one direction.
And this is for
the integer case.
And there has been a lot of
experiment evidence to this.
For the fractional case, it's--
for the fractional case, of
course, again, the bulk--
in the bulk, it will be gapped.
The charge of excitation
will have a gap.
And the edges-- the
electrons and edges
will count to, again, a
one-dimensional electronic
system.
But it's an interacting system.
And it's well known that for
one-dimensional interacting
electron system, the
ground state is a liquid.
And usually it's called a
Luttinger liquid, again,
because the magnetic
field is called
the Chiral Luttinger liquid.
And the main characteristic
of a Luttinger liquid
is it has phonon like
excitation spectrum.
So the density states, the
other Fermi lab, if you like,
vanishes.
But edge, given
the finite energy
excitation, the
density of states,
because it's over some power law
dependence, as indicated here.
And this would have direct
consequences on the current
due to tunneling
either into the edge
or tunneling between the edges.
So if you look at the
current, with a tunneling
current into the
edge, fractional edge,
or the tunneling current
between the fractional edges,
this will have direct
influence, direct consequences.
OK.
The earlier
experiment on this is
the Milliken, Umbach,
Webb experiment
where they look
at the temperature
dependence of the tunneling
current between the edges using
a point contact geometry.
But what I'll do, basically
showing the data Matt Grayson
took, Matt Grayson has, is
following the tunneling,
which is tunneling
from, essentially,
a normal metal into the
edge, which in some sense--
many of you--
I'll show a view where it
will become very clear.
If you just remember the
normal metal superconductor
geometry in superconductivity.
This is just repeat
what I said already.
So what I'm going to show is
the experiment Matt Grayson--
Matt Grayson's data, and using
the sample Loren Pfeiffer
and Ken West grown.
This is the edge
cleaved overgrowth Ray
Ashoori mentioned earlier.
The structure at the end is you
have the 2 dimensional electron
system on this side.
And the 2D electron gas
is confined in a quantum
well indicated here.
Then from the edge
cleave overgrowth
a tunnel barrier is grown,
which is in this case,
be the aluminum gallium
arsenide tunnel barrier.
Then very heavily
doped semiconductors
electron and plus get it out,
which is just a normal metal
electron.
So the experiment is to
inject our tunnel electrons
into the fractional
quantum Hall system.
That's the experiment.
And if you remember from the
normal metal superconductor
tunnel junction, the classical
[INAUDIBLE] tunneling geometry,
which your measurements
are in a tunnel
inject electron into
this interacting system,
the one-dimensional
Luttinger liquid system.
And if you look at the so-called
tunnel conductance, derivative
of the curve, you measure
directly the tunneling
conductance.
So the experiment is just to
measure the IV characteristics,
the IV curve.
And this is just another
view what you have.
This is for the 1/3
stage, the bulk.
Charging stations gapped.
And the edge, or the
actions on the edge, that's
the one-dimensional
Luttinger liquid.
And the experiment is
basically just measuring
the IV characteristic.
You expect a power
law dependence.
And the exponent alpha
is basically, well,
if you see the right--
that's basically characterized
the edge Luttinger liquid.
Well, I think I have
another picture.
This is a more realistic
picture from Matt Grayson.
This is a 2D electron layer.
So you can put contacts
so you can characterize
the fractional quantum
Hall characteristics used
to characterize your sample.
And here is the tunneling
the normal electrode
injecting into that.
OK.
So you can get look at the--
red curve is the
IV characteristic,
the Hall resistance
characteristic
of the 2D electron.
And this is the 1/3 plateau.
This the 2/5.
This is the 2/3.
This is the plateau 1.
And this is the tunneling IV.
And if you look at the edge,
add the fractional 1/3 state,
you would expect the
Chiral Luttinger liquid--
expect to have a Chiral
Luttinger liquid.
And the IV, you should have--
you expect the power law
dependence with an exponent.
It's expected
actually to be for 3.
This is the first piece of
data from Albert Chang's
early experiment.
And this is right at
filling factor 1/3.
We know the bulk is gapped.
And the edge, we expect to
have the Luttinger liquid.
And there is more
than two decades
as the power law, clear power
law dependence indicator.
And the power is
2.7 is sufficiently
close to the
expected value of 3.
Which Matt Grayson as he looked
at a large number of samples.
On each sample, not
only at the 1/3 or 2/3,
also away from
those at a large--
you know, just continued
a various magnetic field,
very close grid look at it.
How do they look?
And surprisingly, when
even you're not at 1/3,
I think it's great.
When you're away from
the 1/3, you also
have the same power
law dependence.
And in this wide range
from 15 Tesla to 7 Tesla,
you all have this
power or dependence.
It's a matter of fact.
This power law,
this is semi-local.
This is [INAUDIBLE] plot.
This power law dependence
would cover, basically,
about four decades.
I think in a range of
certainly unambiguous.
And in the next few view graphs,
I just flip them very quickly,
it just the fit we made.
The fit is to a theory--
well, you can even just--
you can use just a resistor
network the same way.
This fits with
[INAUDIBLE] theory.
This is right on 1/3.
His fit gets 2.8, where
Albert Chang had earlier, 2.7.
And this is the higher field.
And the fit, again, this is
about four or five decades.
It's about 4.2, that fit.
And again, you're
away from the--
I'll just very quickly flip to
give you some sense, the fit.
This is probably about
three decades or so.
And that give a
power law about 2.5.
And this one probably
narrower range, but still--
no, it's not.
It's still about four
decades, about four.
So I just want to mention--
what I want to show
is, if you take
all his data from the
power law dependence,
the exponent is alpha.
And all the detail
plotted up, this
is from these four samples.
These circles are Albert
Chang's early data.
They essentially all fall
roughly in a straight line.
I mean, the immediate first
surprise-- it's surprising as--
when you're away from
the plateau region--
away from the fractional
quantum Hall states,
the bulk is not kept.
The bulk has conduction.
But the edge state, the
Luttinger liquid picture,
the edge mote, which
are Luttinger liquids
are still just proper
description of it.
And the other one, of
course, that dashed curve
is a theory from Shytov,
Levitov, and Halperin.
And this discrepancy between
experiment and theory
I think still remains a problem.
The other point I
want to just mention
that for the filling factor
one and higher in this region
is expected--
the edge mold, channels
are Fermi liquid.
And the exponent is just your
normal IV curve, normal ohmic,
and it is expected to be 1.
More recently, Michael
Hilke, who was a post-doc
at Princeton, looking into
between basically between one
filling factor--
well, one somewhere here
just exploded out more data.
And in data, this is flatten
out 1 occurs of earlier,
but indeed continues.
But his sample, or the sample
he looked at, the data to date
is basically is not good enough
to say anything about what
about the composite
fermion ground state at 3/2
or the 5/2 at those
particular fittings.
That basically is all I want
to say in relation to tunneling
into the edges of the
fractional quantum Hall effects.
Now, I would like to come
back to the even denominator
fractions in higher
Landau levels, Landau
levels for the Landau index
N equal to 1 and higher.
This is Rui Du's data
on samples actually
Loren Pfeiffer
and Ken West grown
in, I think, it's in 1991 this
data, or early '92, or so.
But the point, I
already mentioned,
if I look at the 5/2,
there's clear minimum.
It's very different
from the 5/2,
very different from what
you've seen, 1/2 and 1/4
for the composite fermion
signature in the data.
But more strikingly is when
you go to 9/2 and 11/2, which
is for the Landau level index
n equal to 2 for the 9/2, 11/2,
and 13/2.
And they give a sharp,
very large resistance peak,
very strong resistance peak.
And it depends on the current
orientation which direction
you measure the resistance.
In the 90 degree off resistance
direction, it's a deep minimum.
And in order to be able to go
through the data later more,
it's kind of confusing once
told the magnetic field.
I want you to keep
in mind two things.
One is these lines,
these vertical lines
indicates the easy
conduction direction.
If you measure the current
that direction, in this case,
the resistance does not
have resistance small.
Perpendicular to
that direction, it's
a hard conduction direction.
So this is measured
at perpendicular.
And the hard direction
is x direction.
And the easy direction
is the y direction.
So that's one point I
wanted you to keep in mind.
The other point is that in
addition to this sharp peak
there are also other structures.
And these structures, they don't
fit the fractional quantum Hall
scheme.
They don't fit this
1/2 or 2/3 or 2/5.
And when the temperature goes--
you know, when you lower the
temperature as indicated here,
and everything disappear,
just this spike,
for this current direction,
this spike dominates.
And in addition to that,
because I want to mention,
this is a sample in
almost a decade ago.
And the samples grown in
those days are not rotated.
So you can't have some
very density gradient,
some very small.
In this sample, the
density gradient
is sort of about or less
than 1% in this direction.
But I think if we look
at it very carefully,
it's very convincing this
anisotropy difference cannot be
attributed to this
slight density grating.
But I am going to show you the
data on the next view graph
from Jim Eisenstein in Caltech.
Those are sample were
very recently grown.
They're rotated, and
there is no uniformity.
The results is
essentially the same.
But before I do that, let me
just also say another point.
For this sample, the plan,
the sample plan is 100.
Roy made an x-ray
diffraction very carefully.
The orientation is a
better than 0.5 degree.
And the edges are 110.
They're cleavage edges.
You cleave them.
They're just
essentially right out.
These are a few things
I want to mention.
Keeping that in mind--
well, first let me just show
you the data from Lilly et al,
which are more recent samples
in terms of 2D electron quality,
2D ground system quality.
But the data is
essentially the same.
In one direction,
it's large resistance,
and the other
direction is minimum.
Simple.
And they also look at the
different orientations.
That data you have seen
before is, essentially,
the current measure along the
two different 110 directions.
Whereas here, the also edge 1
rotate the sample by 45 degree.
And you still see
some anisotropy.
But it's much smaller.
So this experiment
actually pinned it down,
located what the
anisotropy direction is.
Now, with this in
mind, now I want you
to just stare at a few foils.
We'll go through the overall.
First, this one is a
temperature characteristic.
Anisotropy is basically, well,
115 millikelvin it's isotropic.
There's hardly any difference.
The anisotropy started
basically about 100 millikelvin,
and it becomes
stronger and stronger.
That's one point.
And the other
structures I've already
mentioned that they don't fit
any fractional Hall states.
And this data curve here
is the Hall resistance.
The Hall resistance has
structure in this region.
Basically, there is some--
at the lowest temperature,
I think is the solid line.
They're clearer
structures, but so far,
we haven't been able to identify
the structures for any--
clearly identify the physics.
The next view graph is
a summary of this one.
Just plot the
temperature dependence.
This is for the 9/2
maximum and minimum.
They are same isotropic,
about 100 millikelvin.
By about 60 millikelvin,
they essentially
saturate the growth.
And this is just plot the
structure on the side.
It does not really fit
to any fractional state
on the side, which is for these
two different orientation.
For two different
current orientations.
That's basically the data and
the futures I want to show you.
The application of a
in-play magnetic field
has a very large effect
on this anisotropy,
thus indicated here.
I probably should-- this is one.
Let me look at it first.
It's indicated here.
I apply a magnetic field.
This is implant field.
I apply a field in the
plane of the sample.
And this is the implant field.
If the implant field is
applied in the difficult--
this is in the easy
conduction direction.
That's the y direction.
If I apply it in the easy
conduction direction,
it suppresses the resistance in
the hard conduction direction.
In the hard direction,
there is a 9/2 large
become small, small, very small.
At the same time, the
easy conduction direction,
the resistance getting
larger, larger,
then getting very large.
If you like this, put a
field, put an implant field
in the easy now changes
the conduction direction
to the hard direction.
And the hard
conduction direction
change to the easy one.
I know it's confusing as well.
What basically I'm
trying to say--
I am trying to say what the
data tells you tells you this.
An implant field makes the
transport along it hard.
It makes the transport for along
the implant field direction
hard.
If you put a large implant
field, at the end of the day,
the easy conduction
direction is perpendicular
to the implant field.
That's really all
I'm going to say.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
does it go back?
When you take it off--
the in-plane field off--
does it go back to the way
it was before?
TSUI: Right.
There are no histories.
It doesn't go back.
And this is consistent.
In some sense,
once you look at it
this one, which would make that
conclusion even more clear.
See, this of course
you put a few already
in the hard
conduction direction.
So in some sense the
things already align
in the right direction.
Actually, you don't
change anything.
But in between,
it changes things.
So at the end, when you
put a field in the plant,
the implant field
orients the system
in such a way at the
end the easy conduction
direction is perpendicular
to the implant field.
That's the message I
want you to take away.
That's really it.
That's what the experiment is.
The gross part of the
experiment, that's what it is.
OK.
Now, the experiment, of
course, has much more detail.
All I'm saying at the
end, so at the end,
if you start out with a
line in the right direction,
the implant field is
perpendicular to the easy one.
At the end, nothing changes,
just integer at some point.
And if it's the wrong
direction, they switch.
Easy becomes hard.
Hard becomes easy.
In between, they're
definitely more than that.
And later, in some sense,
you can feel, well,
the properties are reasonable.
You put an implant field.
Not only you do some kind
of anisotropy related thing,
but you also change the Zeeman
energy, all kinds of things.
But the main thing at this stage
I want it us to keep in mind
is that this is just the same
thing, this plot in anisotropy,
the difference of the resistance
the two direction normalized
by the sum.
But the message, really, is
that you put an implant field.
And that field forces the
system into such a condition
the easy conduction
direction is perpendicular
to the magnetic field.
Our current understanding
of it or at least that's
what I hear people telling me
is the so-called stripe phase.
The understanding
of it has to go back
to Shklovskii and
his collaborators
earlier his paper and
also Moessner and Chalker
on the Hartree-Fock
calculations for the ground
state of 2D electron
system in a magnetic field.
What they find is they find
for Landau index bigger
and equal than 2 and the
charge unidirectional.
This u stands for
unidirectional.
Charge of density
waves state is favored
over the fractional
quantum Hall state.
I have sort of a
cartoon of a picture
here just try to give
you some flavor of what
all those big words mean.
In some sense what
it means essentially
is that a possibility
when you go
to when you're at 9/2 filling,
the system face separates.
It separates filling
factor 4 whole states
and for that in fact are
five Hall liquids, four five
for these stripes.
So if I look at the 2D density.
And basically this
was a density wave
with this as my periodicity.
That's really the only point
I tried to convey with this
Very recently, I think
must be too late.
I got lazy.
I didn't write.
It's Jungwirth.
I think it's MacDonald,
Girvin, and Smrcka.
They have calculated
the anisotropy energy
when you put it
in plain and they
find this they implemented a
few tends to align the stripes
perpendicular to it.
What they're finding with say
if the stress this way they
playing field you put a few
at the end of the day in prime
you will tend to align
these and anisotropy.
And it's just such a line
that drives perpendicular
to the plane.
In that sense in a sense
well we just since we
don't have a transport theory.
We don't really know
how to go trends for us
in these phase separation.
I would say in this
direction, I try
to indicate these are
the edges there's four.
Four that would be a
lot of four edge states.
And the edge states can't
there are compressible,
bulk are incompressible.
So this certainly
is easy interaction.
It's a long stripe.
So the magnetic field
tends to make a stripe.
For the stripe model,
stripe face model
with a line that
perpendicular to the magnet.
In that sense, it's consistent.
This was the
experimental observation.
So qualitative are
the main features
of the experiment or
the experimental data
is consistent with
this stripe phase.
For this picture,
of a cross to relate
to more qualitatively
to the experiment
and also the more
detailed structures.
You'll need a data
transport storage.
In particular, how
do you transform
a charge in this kind of model
across the stripes in these
in the artery FARC model.
There is also, in
addition to the stripes,
is there a source
of bubble phase.
So you know just a
while can one attribute
those additional
structures in that region.
Other than that peak,
we've run them on half.
Can one attribute
that or assigned
to be the bubble phase?
I think we have to wait and see.
Let me see.
OK.
The next part let me
mention, go with it
and you could wind
up with a 5/2.
Or as Horst has already
pointed out in his talk,
let me go back to
this earlier data.
You see that it's
Horst's data also.
Basically I want
to remind you as
for why you have same story half
earlier with 1/4 essentially.
The campus of fermions
signature essentially
is just a very broad minimum.
This is the data in
1987 which I mentioned.
But if you look at a 5/2,
this structure the minimum
is much stronger
than was expected.
The more detailed
result, the more detail
expressed that it was.
On this view graph, when
you change the temperature
from hundreds Kelvin to the
lowest about 25 millikelvin.
This middle amount
becomes very strong.
It looks like a--
it certainly is not very
different from the natural 1/2
or 3/2.
And when you look at
the Hall resistance,
that's this data here.
It clearly shows clear deviation
from the classical Hall.
And this certainly
strongly suggests the 5/2.
Or the 5/2 could be or maybe
a fractional quantum Hall.
The more recent data you have
seen already Horst has shown.
Those are the dirty
that are using
the microkelvin in
Gainesville that you can fit.
It's already mentioned somebody
pine and shot and Dwight Adams
microkelvin lab.
And the experiment
here is 5/2 clearly
shows you are indeed cooling
the electron temperature.
So the electron temperature
is very, very clear.
That's one point but you
are not at all on that.
Let me just mention
to you once you
could blow the time to run
at the lowest temperature
indicator here.
And there is a
very clear plateau
quantized to the
quantum number 5/2.
Just essentially using
the sort of calibration.
And as you calibrate
against something else,
this is quantized actually
to better than 2 ppm.
The limitation is,
as you know, really
didn't it just to install know
instrumentation was designed
for that or quantizations.
So this clearly says
the 5/2 stage is indeed
a fractional quantum Hall state.
Indeed, at incompressible
fluids that are pressing,
there are two candidates.
Or at the present, or I should
say, through all the years,
two candidates for
the ground state.
What is the ground state?
One is the single
state of what usually
is called Haldane-Rezayi
hollow core type.
It's basically the interaction.
Potential has this
particular hollow core model.
One is this not.
And the other one is
the Pfaffian state.
Whenever you have
so many of you.
But what was already mentioned
in the Pfaffian, which
is the p-wave pairing of the
composite Fermi compounds,
or is one to some detail of
the BCS type of candidates.
The early support for the
experimental support evidence
or--
the support from the
experiment in the early days
for this singular state is
the total magnetic field
experiment.
See, one way to view
the total magnetic field
is since the electron system is
two dimensional indicators here
you can increase the
total magnetic field
without changing.
Or put it away, keep the
perpendicular field constant
and still increase
the total field.
Of course, the fractional
quantum Hall correlation.
The correlation give you rise
to the fractional quantum Hall
state in the polarized.
In the simplest
case, it's just so
that this is the given
by that, or the simplest,
it's the perpendicular
magnetic field.
Whereas the Zeeman
energy is related
to the total magnetic field.
So by totaling the magnetic
field, essentially,
you keep the perpendicular
field constant.
You can-- one of
the simplest ways
to view this, the only thing
you do nothing to the system,
except you're changing
Zeeman energy.
That would be the simplest
way to view the total field.
So if you do that, view that way
and do the total magnetic field
experiment, this
is the earlier data
from Jim Eisenstein
and Bob Willard.
This is a 0 magnetic field,
very strong about 5/2.
When you total magnetic
field, that meant a decrease.
As you increase, when you total,
you increase the total field.
Basically, this happened
a total field earlier.
Or so for some test like
now is five some Tesla.
But the perpendicular
view is the at this point.
It's 4.8 Tesla.
And by the time the pearl field,
or Zeeman energy increased
about 5.7, it's very weak.
By that time, more than 7
Tesla for the total field
are the amount of energy, then
this 5/2 structure disappear.
Or the 5/2 status quenched.
This in some sense, was
the strongest support
for the single stage.
But very quickly there, the more
recent experiment makes this.
It certainly shows there
is a problem with this.
Now, this was the simplest.
One is shown by this data
here the state at the 5/2
is still equally strong and
appeared to bow through.
And I have tested
almost 13 Tesla.
That's very large,
say, about an inch.
So that's one problem.
I think it are more
definite problems
of this sort of suggests
maybe the singular state there
is something not right.
And so the other problem came
in some sense became more clear,
became clearer, more recently.
That's the total few
experiment you have already
seen the total few related
to that 9/2 earlier.
Now, it's essentially
the same experiment,
the same type of experiment.
I just looked at
the data at 5/2.
What do you do if
you look at the 5/2?
In this case, the
in plain field is
put along the hard
conduction direction.
The hard conduction direction
is for the 9/2, for 5/2 here.
This is isotropic anyway.
So that but no you
put it in for you
once you put it in plain view.
Then you see that
become an isotropic.
Then depending on what direction
you've eventually in the plane
field is sufficiently large.
So you have one direction
becomes hard to conduction.
The other direction is
the easy conduction.
This is what the implant
field in the hard conduction
direction.
Put an implant field
in the other direction,
again, it's the same thing.
At the end when the field
is sufficiently large
that you get because the system
becomes an isotropic 5/2.
In the easy conduction,
for the 9/2 easy conduction
direction becomes larger.
And it is difficult to come
down the direct direction
it's easier.
So the main message here on this
is you put it an implant field.
Or do a total experiment.
But keep on tilt
toward or even higher
than you'll find
now of an isotrope.
So what you have seen
earlier just the suppression
of the minimum.
That's only part of the story.
So after you keep on totaling,
it's not only suppress.
The orient disappear.
But if you in the
right direction
are actually in them, to measure
it in the right direction
you get a maximum.
That's really the main message.
The other is just put these
data since I have all the data.
So plot it up.
The really the main message.
And somewhere here, or
this say like in this--
let me just not even bother.
That's just the plot.
But what I want to
show you is this
is the data from Lilly and
Eisenstein from Caltech.
It's the same result
as it put it here.
You produce a strong
and isotropic transport.
And you find what you
put in making it a feat.
So what the experiment says,
well for this experiment
tell us this that dominate a
third of the total experiment,
the dominant effect.
It's not the same as
the dominant effect
is in plane field is
induce anisotropy.
It's stated this
anisotropy energy
we see in something like this,
the hard to find calculations.
So the dominant effect is in
plane view induced anisotropy.
Not as a Zeeman energy.
So the imprint field of
what it does destroys the--
it destroys the 5/2
fraction of whole states.
And in its place, it creates a--
if we use the 9/2 state, or
if we believe the 9/2 state,
is that a rational charge
density wave state grants that.
Then it creates a unidirectional
charge of density.
We've stated that's
the stripe phase.
And the experiment you see
the total few experiment which
really is a phase
transition, phase
transition from
this Pfaffian state
or p-wave paired state of
the BCS type to stripe phase.
And this transition is
driven by when you apply
this in plain magnetic field.
There is a pre-print.
I think I have the--
there are two pre-prints.
One has three names.
One, two I think is the one
that Rezzayi and Haldane.
Their calculation is a finite
number, a certain number
electron calculation.
Their calculations
sort of kind of
showed that for
the spin polarized
system and, essentially,
the far field state energy.
And stripe phase energy
are very close together.
So there we see if you
can change the interaction
potential.
Some more it's very
easy to change it
from one to the other.
That's right.
I think my time is up.
I have already said hard
to see anything of what.
Let me just read this these
few words, then I'll stop.
OK.
Which basically I was going to--
I was going to say this.
The picture that has emerged
from a more recent experiment
is that the states of a clean--
I sort of emphasize a clean
two-dimension electron
system is magnetic field.
At fractional fillings for
the Landau levels 1 and 0,
is the first four if you
count the spin levels.
Landau for filling
factor is bigger than--
roughly bigger than 1/6.
You have a fractional
quantum Hall liquids
at the odd
denominator fractions.
And the even
denominator fractions,
you have is composite
fermion guess.
If a composite fermion liquid
in the lowest Landau case.
And you go to 1 for 5/2.
Which you have very
likely, I think.
Sort of it's p-wave paired.
Then for n bigger than
2, the higher levels
it appears I think the
current data sort of indicates
Hartree-Fock ground
states has a lower
energy than the fractional
quantum Hall states.
I will not have
time to say anything
about the winner crystal.
But it's believed
in the clean system
for the filling factor, less
than 1/6 there's no crystal.
But in real life, of course,
the physical phenomena we see
are always in play.
The results of it interplay
between this order.
And electron-electron
interaction.
It turns out this crystal case
for that regime in the water,
it becomes very important.
And this order at
the present certainly
is one of the most
difficult problems.
And we really don't know
how to characterize it.
I better stop here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LEE: Thank you, Dan, for
the very current update
on this exciting story.
Obviously, it's still ongoing.
There may be time for just quick
questions from the audience.
Since we are running late,
maybe we should just move on.
Let's thank Dan again.
[APPLAUSE]
KASTNER: So now I'm going to
give John Joannopolous the joy
of introducing Bob Laughlin.
JOANNOPOULOS: Thank you, Marc.
It is, indeed, with
particular pleasure and pride
that I introduce our next
speaker, Bob Laughlin.
As I'm sure many of you know,
Bob's talents his brilliance
and creativity as a theorist
have by now become legendary.
But what you may not know is
that some of these talents
actually overflow into other
areas, such as music, and art.
It turns out that Bob is
an accomplished pianist.
He is also a composer, a
composer of classical music.
He's written for
piano concertos.
He's also a skillful
sketch artist
and a very clever cartoonist.
You can see-- you can
find some of his work
on the web on his home page.
Actually, some of
my favorite cartoons
are jibes at the
National Science
Foundation, which Bob calls
the National Seance Foundation.
And in the first two talks,
we saw some very beautiful
and pioneering experiments
led to the discovery
of a new two-dimensional
electron-electron system
with some very
unusual properties.
And, of course, now the
question was, how can one
account for these experiments?
How can one understand what
the nature of this system is?
Now, interestingly,
historically,
fascination with
two-dimensional fluids
actually dates
back to antiquity.
The first written
record that we know
of appears in
Babylonian cuneiform
about 4,000 years ago, about
the times of Hammurabi,
and describes a kind of
divination known as lecanomancy
where the diviner, or the
baru, as he was called,
would drop little droplets
of oil into a bowl of water
and then would
very, very carefully
study the nature and
intricacies of this expanding
film across the surface.
And in doing so, there by
prophecy the fortunes of kings.
And so it came to pass that
it would take a modern day
baru, Bob Laughlin, to decipher
the nature of the intricacies
of this novel two-dimensional
electron system
and lead to, really,
what is a truly
beautiful theory of a
new state of matter,
a novel quantum fluid with
the fractional charge quasi
particles.
And so please join me in giving
Bob a very hearty welcome back
home.
[APPLAUSE]
LAUGHLIN: It's always
a pleasure to be
back here at the place where
they number the buildings.
I was many times in this
wonderful lecture hall
not listening to physics,
listening to music mostly.
MIT's music program is,
obviously, very special.
I remember vividly hearing
Murray Gell-Mann here
confuse us all about quarks.
It was at MIT that I first
heard Ray Dingle talk
about heterostructures
and all the amazing things
they could do, demonstrating
elementary quantum mechanics.
I later heard some great
stories about Ray from Horst,
and I hope any of you that
put enough liquor in him
will get those stories out.
Now, I apologize for
this lengthy wordy thing.
But I have a point to
make this afternoon that
is summarized succinctly in it.
So it is about my story of why
the fractional quantum Hall
effect is important.
It's fascinating
for lots of reasons,
but it's important in
my view because it shows
experimentally-- this is the
key word experimentally--
that both particles carrying
a simple elementary fraction
of the electric
charge of the electron
and interacting by gauge
forces not postulated
in the underlying
equations of motion
can arise in an emergent
manner as collective effects
from ordinary particles obeying
the ordinary laws of quantum
mechanics.
Now, both particles carrying
fractional quantum numbers
and powerful gauge
fields between them
are key postulates
of the standard model
of elementary particles,
something that is allegedly
fundamental in our universe.
And as I'm going to
claim this afternoon
the importance of
these experiments
is that they impugn this idea.
They suggest that maybe such
things in the universe itself
could be emergent,
which is to say.
Could not necessarily be
fundamental at all but just
collective phenomenon.
Frank Wilczek has a
wonderful name for this.
He calls it solid
state imperialism.
And I am the worst of the
solid state imperialists.
At least, I hope so.
Now, on that note,
let me start off
with a thing that's been
a lot in the news lately,
which is the theory
of everything.
Now, this is not the
theory of everything,
because there is
no light in here.
And there is no nuclear
physics in here.
And there is no gravity in here.
And there are no weak
interactions in here
and so forth.
But for chemistry and the world
of physics at people scales,
this might as well be
the theory of everything.
And what I mean by everything
is shown down here.
Now, look, everybody,
I apologize.
I made this view graph
in Stockholm the day
after we just had a press
conference that was completely
monopolized by Professor Sin
who won the conops prize.
And he had, of course,
done fundamental work
in welfare policy.
And you can imagine that
nothing sells better in Sweden
than talks about welfare policy.
And so I was kind of--
I was feeling my oats
here when I finished out
the things that the theory
of everything could describe.
Notice what I meant
by Ebola virus.
Now, one of the
things that these
are-- by the way, those
of you who are not
physicists, what is this?
This is the elementary
Schrodinger equation
for nonrelativistic matter.
And H is the equation of
motion for this matter.
It consists of kinetic energy,
of electrons, kinetic energy,
of ions, coulombic
attraction between them,
and also coulombic
repulsions between pairs
of light particles.
And that's it.
Now, one of the things that this
theory of everything describes,
it is alleged, is
this experiment.
This is not von Klitzing's
original quantum Hall
experiment, but it's
conceptually the same.
So let's talk about
it as though it were.
So let me remind everybody that
the way the experiments work is
electric current is forced
along a sample that's typically
about a millimeter, or even
several millimeters in size.
In fact, this distance
here was one millimeter.
In the presence of
a big magnetic field
pointing out of
the board, then one
measures two voltages
this one between this pad
and the this one
between those two pads.
That's the wiggly line here.
And also between this pad
and that one, and that's
the line with the steps.
And those voltages are
measured as a function
of field strength,
magnetic field strength.
And what the effect is
that at certain values
of the magnetic field are more
precisely certain ranges of it.
The potential drop in the
direction of the current
is going dies away to nothing.
And at the same time,
the whole conductance
which is across the current
path becomes constant
and what Klaus discovered
was that the value
of this constant, which
you can measure accurately
because it's constant, is a
related to the current being
forced by a hollow
resistance that's multiples
of elementary constants.
In this case, the
electric charge
of the electron
and plugs constant.
Now, as of this moment, the
accuracy of this experiment
is about apart in 10 to
the 8, slightly less.
And I ask you all to ponder
how accuracy that big
could come out of
these equations.
You see, everybody who's
solid studying quantum physics
knows that computing things
like air, water, and fire
from this underlying
equation of everything
is a ludicrous undertaking.
It's too hard.
The equations here cannot
really be solved accurately when
the number of atoms
exceeds about 10.
Accurately means apart
in 10 to the 4, maybe.
So beyond that, it
isn't possible to solve
first principles a solution.
So when we get
elementary constants,
Planck's constant and e coming
out of a measurement with 10
to the 20th particles in it,
we have to pause and ask, why.
Why is it so accurate?
Certainly, you can't deduce this
starting from the underlying
equations.
That's too hard.
Now, you may or may not
know accuracy of this kind
occurs all the time--
all the time in physics.
The first examples actually
come from chemistry.
The ones I like to
cite, electrochemistry
turns out to be a
very accurate way
of measuring the electric
charge of the electron.
However, the sexy
physics examples
mainly come from
superconductivity
and the Josephson effect.
The Josephson quantum
of magnetic flux
is the most accurate quantity
known in mensuration aside
from the speed of light itself.
And so there is plenty of
precedent in the physics
literature for many, many
particles giving rise
to accurate measurements
of elementary constants.
And then all those cases we know
the reason for this accuracy is
higher organizing principles the
matter itself is acting in some
collective way that you cannot
deduce from these equations.
You can't go deductively
from these equations
to this behavior, because
the accuracy isn't there.
So the intellectual
problem that's
posed by questions like this
is, what is the principal?
Why are these
experiments so accurate?
Now, a part and 10
to the 8, you begin
to think about
this a little bit.
And you see that, well,
the theory of everything
that I showed you
actually has corrections.
The biggest one is here, as all
practical purposes, that spin
orbit coupling and things of
that sort in this material
would be parts in
10 the the 4 effect.
The radiation field
actually is bigger,
but it's subsumed by
normalization effects in QED.
However, once we begin to
worry about these things,
then we begin to worry about all
the other possible corrections
to the experiment.
How accurate can it get?
What is limiting its
accuracy, if anything?
Now, there is an
idea that is well
known to people who worry
a lot about the quantum
mechanics of empty space.
And that is that empty
space isn't empty.
Empty space is full of stuff.
That is, the sum total of the
accelerator experiments that
have been done since
the Second World War
have told us that space is a
lot more like a piece of glass
then it is ideal
Newtonian vacuum.
It's filled with stuff.
And so when I talk by
analogy between issues
we have in the vacuum
of space, and issues
that happen in solids--
in fact, this analogy is apt.
Empty space is not empty
in exactly the same way
that a solid is not empty.
So all these
corrections to the laws
of physics in ordinary space
matter, at least in principle,
they matter.
And one of the
questions we have to ask
is, why don't they
show up in mensuration?
Why do all these-- why are
all these little corrections
to the underlying
equations irrelevant?
Now, the answer, of course, is
there's a principle involved.
And in order to talk
about this principle,
I have to remind you all
of something you know,
or teach you it if you don't.
And that is something
we call the principle
of adiabatic continuity.
So here's the problem.
Suppose we've got something
we want to understand,
and it's very complicated
like, for example, the Hall
conductance, but we know
there's a principle involved
that makes it exact.
So we can imagine a
thought experiment
where we perturb the
equations of motion slowly
and interrelate
between lambda equals
0, which is the
thing we're studying
and lambda equals 1, which
is some idealized limit
to the problem.
Then, if it turns out
the thing we're measuring
is constant, as I adiabatically
deform the equations of motion,
then I can understand
what's going on over here
by studying what's
going on over here.
In solid state physics,
we do this all the time
without calling it
this fancy name.
We call it modeling.
But I have to be a
little careful now,
because the thing we're trying
to understand is an accuracy.
And so we can't be
cavalier about modeling
and have to really think
hard about what continuation
principle allows us to
understand something
exact in terms of a model.
Now, the model that we--
like, I would say, let's say
the model would be, I guess,
this end of the line--
that we like to think about
this problem in terms of
is the one shown here.
So what this is is ordinary
nonrelativistic electrons
feeling a magnetic
field B and also
moving in what we call a dirt
potential, or random potential.
Now, at the risk of telling
a joke that will bomb,
the dirt potential
is like pornography.
I can't define it, but
I know it when I see it.
In this case, the
random potential
is something that
we could sketch
but the truth is that, in
physics, we don't know how
to define around a potential.
We only know how to define the
behavior that you see in one.
And the behavior that you see
in random potentials has a name.
It's called localization.
And localization is
an emergent principle
that we know to be true, because
it's been seen in experiments
many, many times.
Now, before we get
to that, let's look
at this random
potential that turns out
is crucial to having
Hall plateaus.
It's very easy to show
that if it's missing,
then you don't have them.
So suppose-- let's do that--
suppose the sample is system
is translation invariant.
So we have some
density of particles
in there and a magnetic field.
Well, then you all know
you can run past it,
make a Lorentz
transformation, then
by the relativity
principle, there
will be in the moving
frame an electric field
across the sample, a current
going along the sample.
And the ratio of the
two after some algebra
turns out to be the
number of particles
per square centimeter
divided by the field
strength times some
elementary constants.
So measurements like this Hall
effect, measurements usually
measure the particle density.
And, in fact, this is a standard
and rather boring experiment
that one does in
semiconductors to tell how
many extra carriers you have.
A corollary of
that idea, then, is
that quantum Hall
effect can't occur
in samples that are perfect.
Because if the
sample were perfect,
it would be measuring the
number of carriers in there.
And the number of carriers in
the sample is not quantized.
Now, let me now tell you
all about localization.
This, unfortunately, is confused
by dimensionality issues.
So let me tell you the old
lore back in the old days when
people were thinking about
three-dimensional system
semiconductors.
In particular, the idea
of localization was born--
it was born in the
mind of Phil Anderson.
The basic idea of it is that
eigenstates of one electron
quantum mechanics, which is
what we're talking about here,
come in two varieties.
They are extended states
and localized ones.
Extended states are contiguous
from one side of the sample
to the other.
And they are capable of
carrying electric current.
Localized states
are the opposite.
They are not contiguous
from one side of the sample
to the other.
And they are not capable of
carrying electric current.
Now, in an actual sample,
it is found experimentally
that not only is
this true, but there
is an energy scale called
the mobility edge below which
all the states are
localized and above which
all the states are extended.
And the way the
system approaches
these this edge is part and
parcel of the metal insulator
transition in disordered
one electron problems.
Now, there was, in the
old days lore about this,
that you couldn't have
localized unextended states
at the same energy.
Because if you did, then the
tiniest amount of perturbation
would mix then, and you'd
have two extended states.
But nobody knew whether to
believe that law or not.
So the way it came
down eventually
was that this was
adopted as true,
because the experiments
told us it was true.
Localization is a phenomenon
that happens in nature that you
cannot deduce from microscopics.
You can get part of the way
there if you cheat and make
some assumptions about
what a random potential is.
But the truth is,
we don't do that.
So the right way to
look at localization
is not as a theoretical
ideas so much
as an established
experimental fact.
Now, what happens
in a magnetic field?
Well, at the time of this
experiment, nobody knew.
Nobody knew what had
happened, and there
were some things we
didn't know, which
was the random potential
should have taken Landau levels
and broadened them.
Landau levels are highly
degenerate manifolds of states.
And the first thing
a perturbation
does to degenerate states
is it breaks the degeneracy.
So everybody
expected the density
of states of this
one electron problem
to look something like this.
And, actually, I think
it's fair to say,
in the beginning, everybody
expected everything
to be localized.
That it should have been
localized in the tail region
was completely obvious from
anybody's point of view.
That there should be
localization in the center
was very non-obvious.
The Klitzing experiments
told us that it was not so,
that there were extended states
in the centers of these Landau
bands.
And the reason is because
it conducted electricity.
So we knew that it must do so.
There were extended
state bands there.
But we didn't know much more
about that in those days.
It was one year ago, I
guess, more like two years
after the publication
of the famous gang
of four paper
predicting or asserting
that localization must be
complete in two dimensions.
And we are, in fact, in two
dimensions in this problem.
So many people felt
that localization
should have been complete
and something else
must have been going on.
Now, as I said, the
experiments told us otherwise.
And now, in the
light of hindsight,
we understand that
localization physics
is different in magnetic fields
than it is in their absence.
In particular, this
problem has a density
of states, which actually
looks like I've drawn it.
It's tails of extent of
localized states separated
by distinct bands
of extended ones.
Now, how do you get perfection
out of imperfection?
This is relevant to the
fractional quantum Hall effect.
So let me lead you down
to this idea historically.
Here is this now
infamous argument to me
which accounts for
why localization
makes exact quantization
of all conductance.
And as Horst said,
the essence of it
is that the system can be
made by a thought experiment
into a charge meter.
The thought experiment which
does that is illustrated here.
So we imagine wrapping
the quantum Hall system
into a loop.
There's a magnetic
field coming out
of the surface of this loop.
I don't know how you do that.
Just do it.
And we will imagine filling
up these one electron
states up to some
chemical potential
that is in the local state band.
Now, rather than computing
currents, which is hard,
let us compute energies and then
take the adiabatic derivative
of the total energy
of the system
with respect to a little
bit of magnetic flux
that's poked through the center.
This is not hard to understand.
It's just Faraday's
laws of induction.
When you change the
flux to the center,
there is some EMF that
winds around the loop.
And if there is current going,
then it will do work on it.
Why is this allowed?
Well, it's allowed by the
fact that the system doesn't
dissipate.
So that if we are in a
region of localized stage,
then the conductance, which
is to say the dissipative part
of the response function,
has to be identically 0,
because localized
things are insulators.
And so that means that this
flux can be put into the loop
and out adiabatically.
So it's because
there's no dissipation
that adiabatic
derivative makes sense.
Now, while one is doing
this adiabatic derivative,
the localized states do nothing.
And the reason for that is
that since they go down,
they don't go around the loop.
They can't tell the difference
between addition of flux
and a gauge transformation.
So it's exactly true
that the localized states
contribute nothing to
the adiabatic derivative.
And for that reason,
I can just erase them,
which I've done here.
Now, we've got a
much nicer problem,
which is little bands
of states separated
by finite gaps in which the
chemical potential lies.
Now, as I do this
adiabatic derivative,
it is not possible for a state
to cross the gap adiabatically.
The reason for that
is that if it did,
it would be coincident in
energy with a localized state
and, therefore, would
have to be localized.
So that's out.
So this little
localized state region
here is like a brick wall.
It prevents adiabatic
motion of states.
And so that means
when I wind the flux,
the only state
motion that's allowed
is from one edge to the other.
Now, the trick to making
this calculation simple
is to make the sample big enough
that the adiabatic derivative
can be replaced by
a differential where
the denominator
is a flux quantum.
Doing this means that
adiabatically changing slowly,
slowly, slowly, stop, maps
the Hamiltonian back to itself
up to a gauge transformation.
And this means
that the system can
have changed its energy
only by repopulating
the original states.
But that is only
possible at edges.
Because only at
the edges are there
states at the fermion energy.
So the current carried is 1 over
C times the change in energy,
which is the number
of electrons,
the number of states, which
are transferred from one
side of the sample
to the other times
the chemical potential
difference between the two
sides divided by a flux
quantum, which is the answer.
So in this view of
accurate quantization,
the proof, if you will, that
localization physics will not
change the quantum
of Hall conductance,
even though the
number of states,
is changing, as is
their occupation,
is that the experiment measures
the charge of the electron.
The electron-- the quantum
of Hall conductance
is quantized because the
electric charge of the electron
is quantized.
And the quanta can be viewed
in this context as the same.
Now, that's historical
perspective.
You can imagine my surprise,
great joy, actually,
when I got this pre-print
from Horst and Dan
announcing their discovery of
the fractional quantum Hall
effect.
So what you see here are--
this experiment is just
the same as I showed you.
We're sending a current along
the axis measuring voltages.
The voltage drop in the
direction of current flow
as, shown here.
The Hall voltage between that
pad and that one is shown here.
And down on the left, you
see Klitzing's effect.
And then up here where there
should have been nothing,
you see a new
feature developing,
and a dip in the
parallel inductance
corresponding to it
failing to get deeper
as you lower the temperature.
No, no.
We checked all that.
We checked for nonlinearities.
It looks very good.
You'll see it hasn't
gotten to 0 yet.
In this experiment, it's
on its way, obviously,
but hasn't gotten there.
So I made a guess based on
my knowledge of these guys
and also the way the
experiment was going, namely
that localization physics
was also happening here
and that it would
be complete when
the temperature was lowered.
Also, if you look at
this line with your eye,
you'll center it
with your eye, you'll
see it's already 1% accurate.
And that was already too much.
There should have
not-- there should
have been no reason for
it to be 1% accurate, even
that accurate.
So there was every
reason to believe
that the effect was the
same as Klitzing's effect,
except at the wrong fraction.
The filling factor, rather
than being integer, was 1/3.
Now, Horst-- here is--
the experiments got better.
Here is a later one.
So the guess was-- right here
is a later one showing the 1/3
plateau, very well-developed.
It's very, very
deep minimum here.
And you can notice also
subsidiary fractions
here at 2/5 and 3/7.
Now, as the samples improved,
fractions of all sorts
began popping out.
And Horst likes
to say, well, what
a neat thing it was
that good old Bob
invented this equation
to explain it all.
But the truth is, I didn't.
And even worse than that, I
was really lucky-- in fact,
the world was lucky--
that samples were so lousy
when the original experiment
was done.
Because had we known about
all these other fractions,
we would have been
very confused.
So anyway, it was a
lucky break for everybody
that this one just
happened to be
the biggest one and,
therefore, the most obvious.
Now, how accurate
is this experiment?
Well, as I told you,
you can eyeball it.
The original ones
were a percent.
The modern error bar is
about a part in 10 to the 5.
And most of us see
the only impediment
to getting it better being
the temperatures to which you
can cool the 2D electron gas.
That means we have
the same problem
with the accuracy of
this fractional plateau
that we had with
the integer ones.
That it's already too accurate
to be explained by modeling.
There really must be
principal involved
to make it so accurate.
Unfortunately, the
localization principle
that we knew won't work here
because any problem that
can be adiabatic continued
to noninteractive electrons
must have integer plateaus.
That's the essence of
the thought experiment
that I showed you.
That means that this quantum
state, whatever it is,
is not continual to
noninteracting electrons
but is rather some sort of
many body effect that involves
the coulomb interactions.
Now, by far, the easiest
theory to make right now
is that this effect is
the same as this one,
except the thing
being localized is not
an electron but a
piece of an electron,
and elementary
excitation of the problem
that has fractional charge.
And please note that I'm talking
in the sense of the principle
of adiabatic continuability.
So I'm imagining a
limit of the problem
where the objects, if you
will, elementary excitations,
become noninteractive and free.
In that case, we
have localization
physics, just as before, but
not localization of electrons.
But instead, localizations
of the elementary excitations
in this state, whatever it is.
Now, I can't emphasize too
strongly that the reason
to believe this is
the experiments, not
the theory that I'm
about to show you.
The experiments
tell you that there
must be fractionally charged
excitations in the problem
because there is no other
way out of accounting
for the accuracy.
The accuracy is the key thing.
There has to be principle.
The principle you have
available is localization.
Localization of things
deformable to electrons,
free electrons, won't work
as a matter of principle.
So, by far, the
easiest thing left
is just to have a
new vacuum where
the excitation is a fraction.
Now, all that was left now
was to invent a prototype
that everybody could understand.
Now, you folks
probably many of you
are too young to remember
that in those days,
there was already a big
literature on fractionally
charged excitations
that goes way, way back
to papers on solitons
by Jackiw and Rebbi--
done here, actually.
And also, work done
by Bob Schrieffer
at Santa Barbara
in systems which
have-- will be called discrete
broken symmetries in them.
So the idea that
there should be vacuo
with fractionally
charged excitations
is not originally to me.
It's due to people who went
before me, chiefly particle
physics and Bob Schrieffer.
So one already knew that
the idea was not nuts.
The only thing left was to
figure out what it might be.
Now, I should tell you when--
I knew about the
soliton work, and so I
made a theory of
this effect based
on an analogy with fractional
quantization in solitons.
And I sent it into
Phys Rev Letters.
And I like to say, thank
god the referee rejected it.
I know later that this
referee was Steve Kivelson.
And Steve pointed out, well,
that your discrete symmetry
breaking that you've
made in your theory
is really continuous
image rating.
It's like the stripe idea,
and that means it's got a pin.
And, therefore, it wouldn't
conduct electricity,
and so the whole
idea is nonsense.
So I got this referee report.
And I said, well,
unfortunately, he's right.
So I need to go
think about it more.
So I thought, well, this thing--
experiments are telling us it
has a great big energy gap.
So when things have energy
gaps, you can get to first base
in modeling them
just by brute force.
So I thought, OK, let's try to
solve the problem by computer,
starting with one electron.
That I can do.
Then let's do two.
I did two.
That turns out to be easier
than doing it on paper.
[BELL RINGING]
What does that mean?
Nothing.
Hello?
Then 3, then 4.
So the model Hamiltonian
one couldn't study
is just a few electrons
that are repelling
each other coulombically.
And for balance, let's put
a little pressure in here
to keep them in these
old calculations.
There are two energy scales.
There's a so-called cyclotron
frequency and coulomb energy,
which is e squared over
the length associated
with that harmonic
oscillator energy.
And the limit we usually prefer
as theorists is this one, where
the cyclotron energy is much
larger than the coulomb energy,
even though in real
samples, we're not always
deeply in that limit.
But it doesn't matter because
of the adiabatic continuability.
This is the right
limit to be in.
So I studied, looked
at these guys,
and solved them, and got
the wave functions out,
and showed them here.
There they are.
These wave functions I'm showing
you are completely meaningless.
I just like to show them.
Then I found those, sure enough.
The little cluster is kind of
doing what the experiments do.
As you increase the
pressure going this way,
the mean square error
changes and jumps,
and the angular momentum
also changes and jumps
as though it's contracting.
It has preferred densities, and
it's contracting discretely.
So I thought, that's good.
Then I said, OK, well that's
what's happening then.
Maybe something like this thing
down here is the ground state.
So I knew this
function is exact.
When the number
of particles is 2,
it's pretty close when
the number of particles
was 3, 4, or 5 and 6.
So I spent several
weeks trying to prove
that it was the
exact ground state
of the relevant Hamiltonian.
Relevant Hamiltonian,
in this case,
is noninteracting electrons plus
a little bit of coulomb balance
potential in the background,
jellium basically,
plus pairwise coulomb forces.
And it wouldn't work,
and it wouldn't work,
and it wouldn't work.
And, finally, I said, well,
it's not going to work.
This doesn't work.
It's a great idea,
but it failed.
So I went in the physics
library at Livermore
and began reading
books on helium.
I thought, oh, well,
helium is like this,
and I could learn from helium.
And the very first
book I pulled down
was Gene Feenberg's book
on many body theory.
And I opened it at
random, and there
on the very page I had opened
was this wave function.
It turns out that this
functional form for many body
problems is used very commonly.
It's called Jastrow form,
and it's variational.
So I thought, oh,
my god, that's it.
The function is an exact.
Wave functions in many
body physics never are.
So the thing is variational.
So I quickly went to
find out how good it was.
Now, just so you folks
know, what's written here,
z 1 through z n
are the locations
of the electrons in the plane
expressed as complex numbers.
So this is a pairwise
difference raised to a power.
The power has to
be an odd integer.
And then because of the
background magnetic field,
it has to be canceled
by an exponential one
for each electron, and the
length scale in this experiment
is the magnetic length
which has been set to 1.
So, as luck would have it,
I was in a laboratory that
specializes in plasma physics.
And the nature of the
calculations that I had to do
were all the same as those
done in dense plasmas.
So I went to my plasma buddies
Forrest Rogers and Hugh DeWitt
and asked them how to calculate.
And they showed me,
and then one by one,
things began to fall into place.
So we squared the wave
function to get the probability
to find the electrons
at various positions.
Integrate out all
but one of those
coordinates, and we get the
density, the charge density
of the state.
And, sure enough, it was exactly
uniform out to the boundary,
and the density is
exactly what we want.
It's one of the ideal density
of a filled Landau level.
The first nontrivial
value of n, by the way,
is 3, which is the 1/3 effect.
Also, one can integrate out
all but two of the coordinates
and get what's called
the correlation function.
And that's important for--
well, here's what it looks like.
So what this is is this is the
density of the fluid given that
as a function of distance,
given that one of the particles
is at the origin.
So in the electron
gas lingo, this
is the exchange correlation
hole of the gas.
And what you see is that the
electrons avoid each other.
So if one electron is at the
origin than the other electrons
avoid it.
Although, in the m
equals 3 state, which
is the interesting one,
they pile up a little bit
at the near neighbor position.
So once you have this
function, then you
can weight it by 1 over
R to get the energy.
Now, just to show you there
was, at the time, a strawman--
which was Hide Fukuyama's--
Hide and Phil
Platzman, I guess--
their Hartree-Fock calculations
for the Wigner crystal.
And so it was possible to
weight this pair distribution
function by 1 over R and find
that the wave function I made
was a little better
energetically
because it keeps the
particles a little bit
farther apart than the crystal.
And so here is total energy as
a function of filling factor.
Here is the strawman
Wigner crystal energy.
Down at the bottom is the
1/3 state I constructed.
1/5 looks like it's
better, and then 1/7
is a little hard to tell.
So on the basis of
this calculation,
I predicted that there should
be one more of these fractions,
namely 1 at 1/5.
When I finished this
calculation, I phoned up Horst.
I said, Horst, Horst, I think
there's another fraction.
He said, really, what?
I said, 1/5.
He said, well, it's close.
What had happened
in the meantime
was that these
guys had discovered
the famous 2/5 state, which,
unfortunately, I did not
predict.
And then they began to
find all sorts of fractions
that I didn't predict
and didn't find 1/5.
And that was, as my father
used to say, cheap thrills.
And then they didn't find
it, and they didn't find it,
and they didn't find it.
And then, finally, I believe
it was Emilio Mendez found it
in this experiment.
Now, there are better--
wait, wait.
[LAUGHTER]
Wait-- there are
better experiments.
I just wanted to show
this one to demonstrate
the lengths to which theorists
will go to declare victory
of their theories.
In fact, modern samples
have a nice plateau here,
although it is one of the
weakest ones ever found.
Well, let's just
get that right off.
Now, what about the
fractionally charts excitations?
Turns out, you get
those for free.
Once you have a uniform
state with an energy gap,
then you can imagine a
little thought experiment
where you poke the sample with
an infinitely thin solenoid,
adiabatically wind
a little flux--
a magnetic flux through
it, a whole flux quantum.
And then once you've done
that, again, the Hamiltonian
has returned to itself just
like it is in the loop problem.
And so you can
remove the solenoid
by gauge transformation.
And this process gives the
next iteration of charge
plus or minus 1/3, depending
on which way you wind.
The basic reason for
this is the following.
That the winding
process does something
complicated near the solenoid
you don't understand.
But far away from the solenoid,
the effect is very simple.
It's exactly the same as in the
integral quantum Hall effect.
It just takes the state and
moves it over by one orbital.
And so the net
charge transported
through an imaginary
Gauss's law box here
is the average charge per
orbital of the ground state,
which, in this case, was 1/3.
One thing led to
another, and I cooked up
these variational wave functions
for the positive and negative
quasi particle.
Z0 here is not a variable.
It's a place locating the
center of this particle.
So it's a quantum number.
These wave functions
came out of the blue.
They were just the
simplest approximations
I could think of that
would look something
like this thought experiment.
Later, Duncan
Haldane and Ed Rezayi
did numerical calculations
on the problem
and found out these wave
functions were vastly better
than they had any right to be.
So these are actually
pretty good representations
of the problem with
coulomb interactions.
What these particles
look like is this.
This is what they look like.
This is a plot of charge
density versus how far you
are from the center
of the particle.
And we want to look at
the solid line here.
That's the positively
charged one.
What you see is near
the center of it,
there is a place where the
charge density of the fluid
is missing.
And when you add up the
deficit, it's exactly 1/3.
The quasi hole wave function
is this dashed line,
and it's the opposite.
The charge density of the vacuum
near the center is in excess.
And when you add it up,
the amount in excess
is exactly 1/3.
Now, with these wave
functions, then it's
possible to compute the coulomb
repulsion of the piled up
charge with itself.
And then compare it with
measurements of the energy
to make such a particle.
These measurements--
measurements which do that,
or which we believe do
that-- are shown here.
This is a plot of the
parallel resistance
versus 1 over temperature
down in the dead center
in a plateau.
And what you see is,
as you cool it off,
which goes to the
right, there's a region
where you get Arrhenius
behavior, transitioning
to what we call variable
range hopping behavior
at lower temperatures.
Both of these behaviors have
lore associated with them.
This is a strong
localization effect,
and this is what you expect
to get very generally
with thermal activation of
particles from a chemical
potential up to a mobility edge.
The mobility edge distance
ought to be something
like the gap of the state.
So one can take this slope and
convert it into an energy gap
and compare it with
what one gets in theory.
Now, when this was first
done, it didn't work so well.
This is a plot of
measured activation
gap versus field strength.
Here, the measurements
down here--
and the theory is
this dash line.
However, shortly
thereafter, Alan MacDonald
realized that the
model is too crude.
There's a big effect
missing, which
is the thickness of the electron
gas in the vertical direction.
So it has a finite thickness.
And when one takes into
account, a good hefty fraction
of the deficit goes away.
And the rest of it--
at least, I just
described too well
being good enough
for government work--
because these this relation
of the mobility edge
energy to the actual
gap is a little
vague in the first place.
Being comparable in size
is enough, especially
when the trend is right.
Notice, everybody, please, that
the energy scale we're talking
about here is quite low--
quite low compared with the
natural coulomb energy scale.
So the fact that has this
trend with magnetic field
and is also the right
size is very significant.
So we got that right.
Now, the last thing I want to
talk about is gauge forces.
It somehow came to
pass in the development
of composite fermions, which
are perfectly right in the way
that the following
amazing property
of these quasi particles
got overlooked.
I think this has
always struck me
as one of the most
important and most amazing
properties of these objects.
And that is that
they exert forces
on each other that are
velocity dependent.
This was first figured out by
Frank Wilczek and Dan Arovas
and Bob Schrieffer who took
the trouble of adiabatically
exchanging two of these
quasi particles theoretically
and discovering that
the so-called berry
phase for adiabatic
exchange was a fraction.
In this experiment, you
get an odd multiple of pi
when the particles are fermions,
an even multiple of pi when
they're bosons.
This particular
multiple was either one.
Between, it's a
fraction, and a fraction
is associated with the
charge of the particle.
What that means
physically is that when
one of these particles moves
in the presence of another,
it feels a fictitious vector
potential as though there were
a solenoid being carried by the
stationary particle carrying
a fraction of the
elementary flux quantum
where the fraction is
associated with the charge.
Now, the really neat thing about
fractional statistics was that
it was figured out about
the same time-- and I think,
actually, before--
empirically by Bert Halperin
through graphs like this.
Bert figured out that if the
fractional statistics were
present, then the quasi
particles themselves could
recondense into new fractions.
And those fractions
would come out
to be the observed ones, namely
2/5, 3/7, and so forth, If?
They had these solenoidal
forces on them.
So this is a total energy
calculation pulled out
of one of Bert's papers.
And we don't have to worry
about the details of it.
Just notice that it has
some interesting features
at the fractions at which the
so-called hierarchical states
occur.
Now, my interpretation
of this state of affairs
has really not changed
over the many years,
namely that the observation of
these fractions other than 1/3
amounts to experimental
proof that the gauge
forces are there.
I mean, the gauge
forces actually
are emergent in
this problem, even
though there is more than
one way to describe it.
The physics of emergent
velocity dependent forces
is definitely present
in the problem
and has physical
measurable effect.
Now, we go back to the premise.
Now, after all is said and
done, what have we learned?
Well, like most wonderful
things in physics,
this particular discovery
has implications.
It was not expected.
It was completely
out of the blue.
It has very many
interesting aspects,
particularly those
relevant to small devices
in solid state physics,
semiconductor engineering,
and so forth.
But the thing that matters
to me mostly as a theorist
is the bigger issue of where
the strange rules of the vacuum
might come from.
And always, when you
have an experiment,
god is on your side.
In this case, we do
have experiments.
We have accurate
quantization, which
is telling us what
that there are, indeed,
fractionally charged
objects in the world that
are collective in nature.
They carry a quantum
of charge that
is as exact as the
electric charge itself,
of the electron itself.
And they also have very
powerful forces between them,
which are not postulated in the
underlying equations of motion
but simply emerge a new
vacuum and a new kind--
fundamentally new kind
of quantum emergence.
At least for me, and I hope
for you too eventually,
this has been an exceedingly
thought-provoking thing.
And I believe and hope that it
will have major implications
for physics of all kinds as
we move into the next century
and millennium.
All right.
That's all I have to say.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
KASTNER: Thank you, Bob.
That was a very beautiful talk.
And we have time, I think,
for a couple of questions.
Yes?
Patrick?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAUGHLIN: Yeah.
Maybe I lied.
Sorry, Patrick.
We have a parody problem.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, here we go.
Here we go.
KASTNER: The picture
that had the loop?
LAUGHLIN: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I also try
to teach this in my class,
but I've never been
able to move on
because I don't understand how
you can go from the derivative
to the discreet--
LAUGHLIN: Excellent question.
Let me answer that now so that
your students will understand
this henceforth.
OK, let me answer
this now, Patrick.
Because you know--
you all should
know that Patrick and
I have been arguing
about this for 10 years.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAUGHLIN: Well, yeah, right.
My hair is grayer than
yours, so I can't admit it.
The answer, of course, is
that when the loop is small so
that there's a
Bohm-Aharonov effect, then
the Hall conductance
is not quantized.
AUDIENCE: That true?
LAUGHLIN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Are you
predicting [INAUDIBLE]??
LAUGHLIN: Yes, but that's
a no-brainer, Patrick.
AUDIENCE: No, but then
it tries to [INAUDIBLE]..
LAUGHLIN: Wait, wait, wait.
Patrick, this is already known.
If you have something
that's one or two atoms,
and one or two
magnetic lengths big,
there isn't any
quantization of anything.
AUDIENCE: So the question is,
how does it depend on help?
LAUGHLIN: Ah, interesting.
Now, interesting question.
Now, nobody knows.
Patrick, you know when you--
I'm sorry.
I'm preaching here.
Look, I don't know
how it depends on l.
What I know is that when
the sample is too small,
you can see it.
It's there, and therefore, the
quantization argument is false.
So one has to be in
the thermodynamic limit
for the argument to work.
And that's because localization
is a thermodynamic concept.
Now, you're absolutely
right that the disappearance
of the Bohm-Aharonov effect
in the thermodynamic limit
is part of the argument.
And I guess the
best answer I can
give you is, like
localizations-- see,
I can't prove that either.
But the scaling hypothesis leads
me to plus experimental facts,
lead me to believe very
strongly in localization.
And so by the same
token, I'd say
that if we have a loop
that's a centimeter in size,
I assure you that you will never
see the Bohm-Aharonov effect.
I assure you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAUGHLIN: Yes.
Now, Ray-- now, Ray--
I made Ray a bet that
an effect that he saw
was due to-- what did I say?
I said it was time-dependent
delays and transport.
And Ray made me
this bet in public
at a semiconductor meeting.
And then, well, should I tell
the rest of the story, Ray?
Well, I don't know.
I think probably we ought
to pay each other $50
and then go have a beer.
What actually happened
was the experiment was--
the voltage in the experiment
was driven a little too hard.
And the effect was an
artifact of the measurement.
So who is culpable there?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAUGHLIN: True.
It's a different artifact.
But I say if you demand the
$100 under those circumstances,
you are a scoundrel.
I think we should buy each other
a beer and call it a day, Ray.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAUGHLIN: Right.
KASTNER: I think on
that note, let's thank
Bob for a beautiful report.
[APPLAUSE]